אז אני רק אגיד למצלמה.
כיום אנחנו בשלישי לדצמבר.
אנחנו
היום ערביים, זה שמביא לדצמבר
מענים את פרופסור יהושע
בן ארי.
כן,
בוקר טוב,
בוקר טוב ומבורך.
אני פרק
ואני
השאלה הראשונה שנשאל אותך כאדם
בהיכרות שלך את עצמך
עד כמה דורות אחורה,
אתה מכיר את סיפור המשפחה
עד ארבעה דורות.
אז איפה? איפה מתחיל הסיפור? שאני
יליד
פתח תקווה,
והסיפור הוא ש
משני הצדדים, גם מצד אמא
וגם מצד אבא זה יכול גם לברכה.
אנחנו דור רביעי בארץ
משני הצדדים בשני הצדדים. דור רביעי בארץ
הם יזיזים או שבפתח תקווה.
האיש הידוע ביותר במשפחה זו
אביו, סבי
מצד אמא,
ושמו היה אדם ידוע יותר. ייאושו השתמטה,
כלומר שיש אומרים
ש
כן. שאם יהושע שטמפפר התחילה הציונות בארץ ישראל
אומרים שאפילו להביא לבן גוריון עצמו
אמר את הדבר הזה
ושמעתי
הוא סב
או
הוא אבא. כשסבא
האף של סבא. כן,
זאת אומרת שזה הדורה. אני רביעי, לא הרביעית אין לו.
הוא הגיע. הוא הגיע בהונגריה, והסיפור עליו, שהתפרסם על ידי ההיסטוריון יעבץ
גם שהוא הלך ברגל
מהונגריה
לסלוניקי
ושם עלה על אונייה
ונסע לאיסטנבול
ומי איסטנבול, המשיך ללכת ברגל לארץ ישראל והגיע לירושלים
בשנת
במאה
ה,
ואני שמעתי בעצמי מפי פרופסור יצחק,
פרופסור
דינור,
שהיה שר החינוך אחר כך ולימד היסטוריה של עם ישראל באוניברסיטה העברית.
היתה לי הזכות והכבוד לשמוע אותו מלמד
בשנה הראשונה, לאחר מלחמת עצמאות בקורס על
ראשית הציונות בארץ ישראל. וגם הוא ציטט את הדבר
הזה שאם יושע סטאמפר
מתחילה הציונות בארץ ישראל
ויביס בספרו במאמר או מספר על כך
הוא שמע את זה זה אני יודע כמה דברים נכונים
שאותו יהושע סטאמפר שהיה בהונגריה והיה תלמיד ישיבה,
ואחר כך יום אחד יתעוררו בו נצרי לאומיות.
והוא אמר למה על ההונגרים היא תקום מדינה עצמאית
ו לבולגרים במקומי אחרים וצריך גם לארץ ישראל,
והחליט לעשות מעשה
והלך ברגל והגיע לירושלים לאישור ישן בירושלים.
כאן נשא אישה,
וכמה שנים אחר כך היה בין האנשים הראשונים שיצאו ב
להקים את תיקח תקווה
וקן, השיר הידוע של סלומון ויש טמפר וזרעך בארנט, באו
לפתח תקווה עם הרופא שראה את היתושים של הקדחת,
וכן הלאה
הוא.
הוא היה גם איש מאוד פעיל, והיה אחר כך ממקימי ארגון
פרדס ופרדסים. בארץ
היה יושב ראש המועצה של פתח תקווה,
והוא נפטר יחסית בגיל צעיר
מאוד, לפני מלחמת העולם הראשונה.
אבל הוא היה עף, סאלי, ובעצם אני נקרא על שמו. יהושע הזה על שם יהושע שטמפפר
ויש להם עוד הרבה בני משפחה שקיימים, כך יהושע
חשבו.
זה מצד אמא ש
קיבלנו את אלי עכשיו משהו. תגיד לי אם זה נכון
שבעצם
היציאה שלו של ההליכה ברגל זה בעקבות מה שהוא רואה באוויר אני באירופה.
כך הוא כותב. וכך הוא אמר וכך גם התבטא במכתב
ואני לא אומר את זה. ההיסטוריון הידוע יעבץ,
כשמספר בין היתר את הסיפור הזה באחד מכתב,
טוען שגם הוא את הדברים הללו,
עד כמה שאני רואים האלה נכונים או לא נכונים מבחינה היסטוריוגרפית,
אם זה ראשית הלאומיות או לא,
הדבר יכול לנתר היום בוויכוח. אבל אני אומר שגם דינור, שאגב
טבח בדעות האלה, שכבר היו ניצנים של הלאומיות הציונית
לפני העלייה הראשונה.
וגם,
כמו שאמרתי לך, בן גוריון חש בכך. ויש מכתב שהוא כתב
בין המשפחה, ויש
מצטט בערך דברים כאלה.
אז הוא האיש הידוע ברגל,
והוא בא ברגל בירושלים.
כך הסיפור. אני לא ראיתי,
לא ראיתי, ואני לא יכול להעדיף
להעיד עדות ראיה
היות והוא נפטר, ואני כבר נקרא על שמו, אומרת לך הוא נפטר.
הוא גם נעשה אחר כך לארצות הברית לגייס כספים. היה איש פעיל ובספרים על תודות פתח תקווה.
מסופר עליו הרבה.
באיזו שנה הוא נפטר?
אני לא יודע, זוכר בדיוק את השנה, אבל אני חושב עוד לפני מלחמת העולם הראשונה.
אוקיי,
כאשר
חשבנו
היו לו הרבה בנות והוא הגיע לארץ כבר כאדם בוגר, אבל לבד לבד. וכאן הוא מנסה לאישה
בת למשפחה
בירושלים,
היישוב הישן בירושלים. איזה משפחה.
אני לא יודע כבר את הפרטים האלה, לא אחרי הקשת. לא, זאת אומרת
האמא של
סבתי. הם מסייעים להם.
דור רביעי
סבתא רבא שלי הייתה משפחה, אולי ותיקה בירושלים. אפילו כולנו קל.
כן,
יש עוד. כן, יש בני משפחה שחקרו. אני לא מתמצא בפרטים האלה עד הסוף
וכדומה,
אבל להיות ואני הוא נקרא שמו. זה היה סיפור שהלך בבית.
עכשיו זה מצד אמא.
אבל הסיפור המעניין, שגם מצד אבא
היו מראשוני פתח תקווה
והאיש שהיה שם מראש ובגלוי כבר יש בו משה צבי
לוינזון
ובעצם לוי
עכשיו בן אריה זה תרגום של לוינזון
ליפסון,
הבן
של
הלייבל של האריה,
ואותו משה צבי למזון, שאגב איש פחות ידוע,
היה גם איש מאוד מעניין.
הוא היה בין מייסדי בשכונת מאה שערים בירושלים
ויואל צבי
יו ר גרין שכתב ספר השכונות מהשברים. אבא של
רובי ריבלין. היום יושב ראש הכנסת
טוען
בהערות שוליים
שאת החוקה
את התקנון של שכונה מעשרים חיוור בו ש צבי
לוינזון
ולא קמ, אלא שהוא נתן לו ביד
את
העותק שאותי כן, וזה היה לפניו
כשהוא כתב את
את החוברת
על מאה שערים, והדבר הזה מופיע
בספרו של
ריבים יואל
ריבלין
על על בשכונת מאה שערים
עכשיו. אותו משה צבי לוויזון הגיע גם כן לפתח תקווה,
והיה גם כן ממי קיבל פתח תקווה. לא מעט
שלושה,
חמישה הראשונים
קצת יותר מאוחר
ועזב את בין השערים. אבל היה קשר בין מאשרים
פתח תקווה.
הסיפור הוא שכאשר בשנה הראשונה
של היבולים הביאו את המעשר ב תהלוכה
מאשרים בירושלים,
והיא
הייתה ממש חלק גדול מהמשפחה, נשאר בירושלים
של אותו משה צבי ובן זונה.
אבל הוא עצמו הגיע
לבית הסביבה וגרם לו בית
וסאבי, שגם לא היה שם מעניין כלב דוב
לוינזון
שערק המנהל בית הספר על פתח תקווה נצח ישראל
הוא סביב,
ואני לא זכיתי
להכיר אותו, וגם
ללוות אותו בזקנתו ולעזור לו
וכדומה.
אז
זה מצד האבא.
זאת אומרת שתי המשפחות ומשפחות במסעדות פתח תקוה. ואז
אבי,
שהיה
בן של אוטוקאד הבדל
לאהוב לוויזון
ושמו היה זאב יהודה
לוינזון. הוא יחליף את השם
לבין אריה
כבר בראשית שנות העשרים. אביך,
אבי
אז סבא זה כלב,
כלב דוב
והסבתא שממלא הסבתא מצד היא אבא, היא אשמה פרדו
וקראו לה עליזה.
היא הייתה גם כן משפחה ידועה
של אדם בשם אשר זליג בלום,
שהיה ירד לאמריקה מאירופה ועלה אחר כך ארצה היה איש עשיר,
ו
והכי זכרונו לברכה, וגם בני נקרא על שמו, אשר
בעוד ש
בני זאב נקרא על שם אבי
אותו זאב יהודה
לוויזון, שהחליף ושמו בנהריה.
הסיפור במשפחה
מבדיל אותך סיפורי משפחה
שהוא
היה בתחילה מורה
באותו בית ספר, רצח ישראל ופתח תיקח
ויו. סבי היה מנהל, סגן המנהל. היה שם עם מנהל מאוד מפורסם, בשם
דוקטור וומבך מגרמניה, אבל במלחמת העולם הראשונה,
נתין גרמני. הוא היה צריך לעזוב אחרי המלחמה את הארץ.
ואז
סבי
זכרונו לברכה.
כלב דוב לאיזון. שימש
בתקופת מה, מנהל בית הספר. וכך היה סגן מנהל.
הוא היה
שם, מורה, מנהל,
הבן שלו גם כן. ואז התלמידים קראו
לוויזון הזקן. ולמי זה אומר צעיר וגם הזקן, היד, האם צעיר.
אז במשפחה סיפרו שאבי עבר. זה לא נעים, והוא החליט לשכנתה
לאברת את השם.
ואז היה במודע בן גוריון בן צבי, כולם תרגמו ו לוינזון. הוא הפך לבן, יהיה
ובי. אז אני נולדתי כבר בן אריה,
אבל
הכימי שלו היו לו שלושה אחים. לא רצו לשנות את השם. נשארו לוינזון,
אבל שניים מהם היו
מהנדסים
חשובים בתל, לטלגרף וטלפון, במיוחד הגדול, גג
שהימים ילדי שכונה נווה שאנן בחיפה.
וב,
כאשר הוא נתמנה למנהל
קול הטלפון בצפון,
נדרש
כי פקיד הממשלה להבריא תשמור.
אבל בן אריה כבר לא היה במודה
אז. הוא תרגם שמונה לוי עוד
להביא קטן
ועוד, אך תירגם גם כן. לוי און,
שהיה מהנדס בצפת.
ואז ארבעה אחים אחד בן אריה,
שניים לביון
ואחד התעקש לשמור את השם
לוינזון.
בכל אופן, זה מצד אבי, גם כן משפחה ותיקה בירושלים.
ואז האבא והאמא הכירו בפתח תקווה.
אמא הייתה בת משפחת שטיינר,
אז
אני רוצה להזכיר, אבל לפני שאני
ממשיך, כדי שתזכיר את השמות של ההורים
הקצת יותר פרחים, אתה יודע עליהם
כשאנחנו הולכים מאחורי איזה סוג של יהודים
מבחינת הקשר שלהם.
מבחינת מסורת, איזה סוג של יהודים היו
סטמפר והמשפחה השניה?
בן זונה.
תראה אם היו
אנשים ממה שנקרא אז היישוב הישן בירושלים, שהקימו
את השכונות הראשונות מחוץ לחומות, כמו
נחלת שבעה הקימוט מאשרים
אנשים דתיים, בוודאי עייף שהיה לכולם להיות
על גבול הדרכים חרדיים,
אבל הרבה יותר אנשים כבר משכילים
שכבר קרו ספרות וקברו את העיתונות העברית הראשונה.
והבית היה מלא מספרים ראשוניים בבית אבא שלי וגם בבית סבא שלי,
אבל כולם היו אנשים דתיים.
אבי כבר היה חבר מזרחי
בצירי המזרחי, וכדו' מעבר
הייתה איזו שכונה
אחווה בירושלים. הנקודה שכמה
וסבי מצד אימא הבן שלי, הוא שוהה סטאמפר. שלומו סטמפר היה ראש עיריית פתח תקווה,
ראש המועצה המקומית
והרבה שנים ראש עיריית פתח תקווה.
ואני. כילד הייתי רץ לישיבות עיריית פתח תקווה
כי אני לא. זה עניין דתי. העניין
והשתתפתי
ומעניין
שחבר העירייה
היה מצד הפועלים, אז גרבובסקי
שנעשה אחר כך חבר כנסת מפורסם
ו
הם היו ביחסים טובים מאוד.
ואפילו אני זוכר פעם את פגישה בביתו של סבא
שגרם מוסכים ונציגיה. תנועת הפועלים היישוב בבית,
והוא היה
אבל איש דתי. יחד עם זה מתקדם כבר הרבה יותר.
אבא שלי כבר ידע הספרות ובעיקר היה בורא וידע. גם ערבית. אתה אומר דתיים עם כיפה.
אז לא היה. יש לך פה כפייה? גם אני גדלתי כנער דתי והייתי הרבה שנים דתי, אבל אז לא היה כיפה.
אז היה מה שנקרא כובע ברט.
לילדים
היה בתי. בתי חרוש. אפילו ביררתי בארץ
היו הולכים עם ברט עם הכיפה נכנסה רק לאחר
הקמת המדינה,
אבל זה היה בא איתי, הייתי אומר
הסבא רבא. משני הצדדים. היו אנשים
מהיישוב הישן
שהפכו להיות בעצם חלוצים, להקים את פתח תקוה לבנות פרדס
קאם, פרדסים וכן הלאה.
חקלאות
הסבים כבר היו הרבה אנשים הרבה יותר מתקדמים.
סבא שלי מצד אבא היה
כתב זכרונות שהיה מנהל בית ספר
ולימד. כמובן שהיו אמונים על התנ ך ועל אבא
הספרים היהודיים,
ומצד
אמא בוודאי.
אמא ואבא שלי כבר היו אנשים בודדים לכל דבר.
ספרות
כולו הספרים שיצאו בעברית, אך אנשים שהוצאה, שטיבל וביאליק,
שאני חושש כי היו בארון הספרים שלה.
המשפחה וכדומה.
אבל יחד עם זה היו שומרי דת
בשבת וקידוש וכל הדברים אחרים.
ולכן כשאני גמרתי
עם עליתי,
בדקתי גם בבית הספר די צר ישראל
כשאמרתי את בית הספר
היות ולא היה בספר תיכון דתי בפתח תקווה,
והם רצו שאני אמשיך בבית ספר תיכון דתי,
גם הכי הגדול זה חובה לברכה,
וגם אני. הם שלחו אותנו ללמוד פה בבית המדרש, למורים מזרחי בירושלים.
כבר אני הגעתי לכאן
כבר בראשית שנות ה
ב,
בשעה אחת או שלוש או משהו דומה לזה,
ולמדנו פה בירושלים. גם המצב בבית. המצב הכספי לא היה כל כך טוב
בבית המדרש למורים מזרחי אפשרות שאתה
חותם על שטרות
ומשלם את שכר לימוד לאחר שאתה גומר את התפקיד ההוראה
אז למה הייתי פה ארבע חמש שנים בבית המדרש למורים מזרח ירושלים,
עוד לפני מלחמת השחרור,
בין אני חושב
עד
משהו דומה לזה
ובאז בעצם נוצר מחסור של מורים גדול
בארץ.
סמינר מזרח היה בנוי ככה
ארבע שנים בתיכון ועוד שנה
סמינר זה חמש שנים. יחד היית גומר גם תעודת בגרות וגם תעודת הוראה,
אבל ייקח לימודית אודות היורה היו בשנה החמישית,
אם כי היית מתחיל קודם.
ואז היה מחסור במורים,
ובאמצע השנה החמישית הוציא אותי
לשנת הוראה
כבר ב
בסוף בראשית
לחדרה
אני רוצה ברשותך עוד, עוד צריך
על המורשת המשפחתית, ואני אגיד רגע, משהו אישי
כבר קשה להסביר את זה.
אני דור ראשון בארץ. כן, ההורים שלי עלו לארץ אחרי שכמה מדינה בשביל הונגריה. כן,
כשאני פוגש אנשים כמוך, אני מרגיש עולה חדש.
אחרת
באיזה מין תודעה הזאת אני רוצה לנסות להבין? לדוגמא, אם
אם תספר לי קצת על הדמויות של אביך ואימך,
מה זה אומר להיות כפר?
הם נולדים לפני שיש במדינת ישראל
יש כאן יישוב יהודי,
אבל
איזה מין חיים אלה היו מבחינת
אם
ההתייחסות למקום הזה שנקרא הארץ היהדות הערביים. השכנים
עוד היו טורקים.
חוקים לא היו. כשאני נולדתי, אני רק בערך
כרגע ההורים
קרן להיות שלהם.
תראה, זה מה שנקרא היא שהוא על התקופה של המדינה. בדרך אני מדבר כבר על תקופת המנדט.
אני לא יכול להגיד על התקופה העותומנית כי אני
לא חזיתי אותם.
אבל כילד שגדל אני יליד.
אתה רוצה לעשות חשבון?
אז
היינו.
וזה היה ישוב. כל הציונים בלב ונפש,
כל השיחות סבוני סביבו תאמין סביב הנושא הלאומי הציוני.
פתח תקווה הייתה מרכז גם של אנשי אצל, למשל,
מהכיתה שלי בבית הספר העממי. ארבעה תלמידים
נפלו במלחמת העצמאות,
והם אני חושב. שניים
מאנשי הסגל בשניים בהגנה
מעולה, גדול בשיווק
היו לגרדום, אבל
בגדול היו יותר. אגב, בירושלים
ומטרתי כבר היו עשירים. הרבה של עסק ישן.
משפחות
יכול להיות, אבל אני יודע בירושלים איזה חמישה, שישה שבעה, אולי אפילו,
אבל שגם בירושלים. זה היישוב הישן, עשה להביא לי שגם בירושלים, אותו יישוב ישן של
אבל הם מאשרים ובית ישראל זה לא היישוב הישן של היום.
בישיבת מאה שערים, למשל, היה הכיוס
היסוד
של תנועת המזרחי העולמי,
והיו הרבה אנשים שם שהיו
אנשים שקרובים מאוד לרעיון הציוני. רק אחר כך
התפתחות נטורי קרתא. והפרק הקיצוני
התחיל בשנות הארבעים שלה
מאת,
ואחר כך יתחזק מאוד לאחר הקמת המדינה. למרות שאגודת ישראל
היה
ויכוחים רבים מאוד עם הוועד הלאומי ולא רצה להיות בוועד הלאומי ועוד דברים אחרים,
אבל זו הייתה
חברה אחרת. אבל אם נחזור לפתח תיק, ואז זה היה כמו כל המושבות
בארץ ישראל. זכרון יעקב, ראשון לציון,
רחובות.
איך את ביתם מדי עכשיו
מרצה באוניברסיטה כותב על אהרון אהרונסון
שהיה יהיה לי זיכרון יעקב, וזה בעצם אולי הצבעה הראשון בארץ.
עימות בלתי רגילה. תזכור,
שני לי כמה על ידי אנשים כמו שלום פיינברג ושר אהרונסון.
הלאומיות הציונית הייתה מאוד חזקה, ואחר כך
תקופת העלייה השנייה, בן גוריון ובן צבי
וכדומה,
וגם בירושלים. דוד דוד ילין למשל, שהיה
ממשיכו אליעזר בן יהודה היה בירושלים
מחייה השפה העברית,
והיו פה כ כ
בית הספרים הלאומי התחיל לקום בירושלים
באותו זמן. זה היסטוריה ארוכה, בוודאי בוודאי מתקופת המדינה,
גם בתקופת
המדינה שבדרך. בתקופת המנדט
היה ועד לאומי הייתה עירייה,
עיריות שהבריות תל אביב. העירייה, העיר העברית הראשונה.
אז אנחנו חונכנו כולנו
על ברכי הציונות.
אני הייתי החבר בני עקיבא תועט אור דתית,
אבל
כל התנועות, הנוער, הנוער העובד
וכל התנועות האחרות היו מאוד פעילות בארץ
הצופים הייתה תגובה חזקה,
כך ש
מהרבה בחינות
צריך לראות את את המדינה על בסיס מה שקרה לפני כן
בתקופה הזו,
ואנחנו טיילנו המון. אני זוכר טיולים
שהלכנו ברגל ופתח תקווה לתל אביב לכל
המקומות, וכמו שאמרתי לך
אני בן דוד ש
היה בעצם ואחר כך היה מעשירי קניה,
ואני זוכר על יום שולחנו
יהודה נאות.
הוא היה אחר כך מפקד חיל התותחנים
ו
והיו במשפחה מהכל והם היו שני אחים, אחד היה
ב
ואצל והשני היה בפלמ ח.
וכך היה גם במשפחות רבות אחרות
והלאומיות היתה מאוד מאוד חזקה, ולא פלא שאחר כך זה הגיע לבסיס
מלחמת העצמאות,
שכל כך הרבה אנשים
שיש אלפים
חללים מתוך יישור של
אלף נפש.
זאת אומרת אחוז אחד בכל
האוכלוסייה היהודית בארץ. עכשיו תעשה חשבון, קח לך את אמריקה,
שזה
מיליון
איש יפלו
שני מיליון, שניים וחצי מיליון אנשים.
מלחמת עצמאות זה היה השיא
של כל מה שהצטבר והוקם
בארץ בתקופת המנדט.
גם ההגנה וגם
הזכרתי ק בפלילים
זה היסטוריה עצומה
ואני חי איתי
את ההיסטוריה הזו. חיינו את המאבק נגד הבריטים, חיות
נושא עניין
האפלה האם את עושה ההגנה?
כשאני כשאני הגעתי לירושלים אז הייתי
אני זוכר עד היום את ההשפעה שלי
בהגנה על טענה,
בחדר חשוך, וכו' וכו. לא
אז כך שזה זה תקופה, אבל ש
שאני הייתי חלק מהתקופה הזאת זה ברור.
על
שני דברים אני רוצה לשאול לפני שנגיע ללידה שלך ולדבר כבר
ככה. החוויות האישיות כן מעבר על המשפחה,
על ההורים
במלחמת העולם הראשונה. מה קרה,
מה,
מה היה שם?
זה דווקא סיפור מאוד מעניין שקרה.
הסיפור קרה דווקא מעניין שקרה בקשר המישהו. משפחה
קרא בסוף המלחמה, כאשר
אני לא יודע אם אתה יודע.
התוכים גירשו
את
תושבי תל אביב
אל מעבר לפתח תקווה, מעבר לירקון וכדומה. אל טורקים ישבו בצד אחד
של הנהר הירקון
והבלתי ביצה השני. במשך עשרה חודשים
ארץ ישראל היתה מחולקת. החלק הדרומי נכבה שלי, האנגלים.
החלק הצפוני
נכבש על ידי, היה עדיין בשליטת הטורקים
ופגזים נפלו מעל פתח בדיקה
ויוצאו את הוא סבא שהזכרתי קודם שלמה שטמפפר. בביתו
יתכנסו חלק גדול מבני המשפחה
ו פגז נפל בתוך
חסר הבית ובן דוד
של אמא שלי
פישל הופמן
נהרג
מפגז ואחותה איבדה עין
ועד לאן היא זוכרת תמיד. וגם אם היא נפצעה קצת
והייתה טראומה נוראה של הפחד,
שק שפרצה מלחמת העולם השנייה.
אמא שלי, זכרונה מבחן, נבהלה שיבוא הסיפור
של מלחמת העולם הראשונה והיה רעה והיו תנאים קשים מאוד בארץ.
ואז אבי
לא היה בבית. הוא ידע אנגלית וגם ערבית, והזוג עבד כמתורגמן.
בצבא הבריטי התחילו במעורבות,
ואחר כך
המלחמה פרצה. בסוף
הוא עדיין היה קשור
ו אמא שלי פחדה להישאר עם ארבעה ילדים ופתח תקווה, הרבה תנאים של מלחמה.
אז היא אמרה לנו בואו ניקח את שלושת הבנים והביא אותה אל אחותה פה בירושלים.
והיינו פה בירושלים בשבועיים ימים.
עכשיו אני לאחרונה עשיתי עבודה גדולה מאוד על ירושלים
היהודית החדשה בתקופת המנדט, שזה מבוסס על מפקד
של יהודי ירושלים.
טסה בספטמבר.
זה החודש שפרצה מלחמת עולם שניה,
ופתאום להפתעתי הגדולה מצאתי את שמי והמפקד,
למרות שלא הייתי גר בכלל בירושלים, אלה הייתי שבועיים
והמפקד נפל בדיוק ושם כתוב בבית דודתי.
כשסאם הופיע כל המשפחה.
כתוב שבות
שלושת
שלושתנו, אני ושתי אחרי
אורח אורח רואה
כי דודתי במפקד
רצתה גם לרשום עצמנו,
וכך היה. ניצחתי
בתוך המפקדה. וגם בספר שלי
שיצא לאחרונה על ירושלים, הבית החדשה בתקופת המנדט,
אז מלחמת העולם הראשונה. את הטראומה
אצלנו במשפחה.
אני זוכר כילד הייתי אני חושב, אז בן
שמונה או משהו דומה לזה.
פרצו מאורעות,
ושוב אבי לא היה אז בבית. ואז אני זוכר עד היום כתמונה שאמא
שלי רצה לבית הספר והשפה אותנו עם שלושת הילדים, ומהיר מהיר הביתה
להתחבא.
ואנחנו רצנו אחרי על הבית ונכנסנו.
עד שהתברר אחר כך שם הוראות כי פתח תקווה היה לה גם
בפרעות תרפ פרטי, ארבעה הרוגים שנפלו.
אחד מהם
שאל אומר שהוא מכבי אבשלום
וידועים מאוד. ואנחנו, כילדים היינו נוהגים.
קוליו כל שנה ביום הנפילה שלהם, במהות ערפאת,
ללכת למצבה,
ו
והיה אירוע שלם טקס
אברהם שפירא,
השומר האגדי של פתח תחתיו וכדומה,
גר שני בתים מהבית שלנו
ופתח תקוה.
כך שאני גדלתי. וחונכתי,
התחנכתי
הקולני, הסיפורים של תקופת המדד
בפתח תקווה,
של מושבות אחרות, של ארץ ישראל,
של כל מה שקורה בארץ.
אז
אוקיי, עכשיו, לפני שאני רוצה להגיד להם ללכת. אבל
הרי תספר לי
קצת על אביך, אבל אמך על הדמויות, על השמות שלהם
ומה הם
קצת אני נמצא ביוגרפיה
על ההורים.
יש לך רומן?
לא חשוב. אני בינתיים מסתדר.
תראה, אבא שלי, כמו שאומר לך הבן של משפחה
שמו,
כמו שהיה זאב יהודה.
אבל אנחנו קראנו לו זאב.
וזה ונקרא בשמו.
והוא
הוא היה למד
בסמינר מזרחי בירושלים
ואחרי טייס, דבר שנקרא ישיבת המשתלמים. זה היה איזה מין משהו לאחר
הסמינר
וגמר את זה
ו
היה דם, הייתי אומר משכיל,
ובעקבות זה אחר כך גם מלמד שפות.
והוא
עבד בתחילה כמורה,
ואחרי שהוא
גמר הצליח מאוד בתפקיד ההוראה.
הציעו לו לעבור ולהיות מנהל בנק, סניף בנק בפתח תקווה,
והוא הלך הזה. לא היה לו השכלה בהרים של בנק
ו לאסונו. אחרי שנתיים שלוש שנים קרה משבר גדול עם שם את המשבר של
משבר כלכלי, שבנקים בכל העולם פשטו את הרגל.
היו כאלה שניסו להשוות את העניין של הבנקים
בארץ במשבר האחרון בעולם, לאותו משבר של
אז. אם אני הייתי אומר ש
שהוא
בשנות העשרים לימד כמורה אז כי ונראה ב
או משהו מזה עבר
שבע
ו פרץ והבנק שלו פשט את הרגל והוא כמנהל הבנק,
היה נמצא במצב קשה,
ואז הציעו לו לשלוח אותו, נסעה לצרפת לכמה חודשים. אני לא זוכר לראשונה שנתיים.
שם, אגב, גם למד צרפתית
וחזר ארצה. הוא ידע ערבית על בוריה, כי יש שגדל
במקום
והשפות האלה היו חשובות לו.
אז
הוא עבד איזה זמן. כמו שאמרתי לך ב כשהוא
כמתורגמן הצבא הבריטי,
וכי הוא ידע ערבית וידע אנגלית, והיא ידעה עברית,
ואחר כך הוא אפילו הצליח להתקבל לעבודה אצל עורך דין מפורסם בתל אביב
בשם פיליפ ג'וסף
פעילים. ג'וזף
היה
אה
אחיו של שר האספקה, ואשר הקיצור דב יוסף.
אבל כשהיא פרצה מלחמת העצמאות טפילים. ג'וזף ברח מהארץ המר, עזב את הארץ וכדומה.
ואז
אבי,
אלו הבעיות, יגיע אחרות של פרנסה.
אבל הייתי אומר מבחינת הזה הוא היה איש מאוד משכיל ומאוד
בעל ידע,
אבד. אבל בגלל משברים שונים שהיו קודם משבר הבנקים, ואחר כך העניין
שמורות שיושב
היה קשה,
כנראה שהוא עסקים. דב יוסף גם בעניין של קניית קרקעות מכפרים ערביים
וכדומה, ולכן די, בעיקר הרבה
בכפרים ערבים.
אני לא יודע אם מזה או לא מזה במשפחה.
חושב שמזה ובאים כאלה הורחק, החלה במחלת השחפת בהחלטות רעות,
והוא נפטר בגיל צעיר יחסית. בזמן מכם פחות יותר ביד אחר נכבה משנת
כשהיה בן שישים בסך הכל.
ואני, כשאני התחתנתי עם אשתי, הוא עדיין היה בחיים. זכרה.
אבל זה כשזה ונולדו. כבר הוא לא היה בחיים. ואז חשבנו
היינו תחת
הטראומה הזו וקראנו את זה, והיא שהבן הבכור שלנו
חשבו,
איש מעניין מאוד, אבל
לא שפר, לא גורלו, נאמר בחיים
ממשבר למשבר.
אמא היתה אישה,
בין
היתר הייתי אומר פשוטה, עממית. היא גמרה, אולי התיכון
אני לא יודע,
לא התיכון עם אמי, אבל היא באופן עצמאי
ילדה אפילו לקרוא קצת בהשפעה של אבא
האנגלית
היתה קוראת הרבה מאוד ספרים,
אבל את האנה, אינטליגנציה טבעית בלתי רגילה. אני חושב שהייתה אישה חכמה
וגם היתה. אני אומר צדקת.
אני זכיתי בפרס ישראל
ואומר סליחה,
זכיתי עוד לפני כן בפרס ביאליק
ו
זה היה כבר, אולי, אני חושב ארבעים שנה.
ולפני שנה שנתיים שלוש
חגגו,
באים שנה לפרש ביאליק. אני לא זוכר איזה אירוע.
ואז הזמינו את כל חתני פרס ביאליק לטקס והיה בתל אביב, בבית הקברות טרומפלדור,
איפה ש ביאליק
וקבעו.
ואז
המנהל היום אבנרי, איש
יקר וחשוב שהוא מקל על ביאליק,
אמר לי כל אחד מאיתכם מתקיים. צריך
לומר משהו, לקרוא יצירה מהשיעור.
אז אני אמרתי אני אקרע את
הראש של
חיים נחמן ביאליק
אימי זכרונה לברכה,
ואני לא יודעת תקרא פעם את השבע. אימי, זכרונה לברכה, הייתה צדקת גבוהה
ושם מתאר אישה
שבאמת
כל מעשיה, מאסיב, חסד ועזרה
לשני ו לזולת וכדומה.
זה היתה
אמא שהייתה אישה מאוד שמא מלא
רבקה קחי נקרע
רבקה
שטרבר וחגר לוינזון.
היא הייתה מאוד אהובה על כל בני משפחתה וכדומה. היא ריכמ ימים,
אבל גם כן נפטרה
כבר הרבה שנים.
אבל
עכשיו כשאתה מנהל ב
אתה מניח
מרתה
בתוך הסדרה של ארבעה ילדים? כן, אני השני אתה שני
ועד
עכשיו נשאר לך כאדם. כן.
מה הזיכרון הראשון שלך. התמונה
הראשונה שחרוטה הליכה
אני לא יודע. אנשים מדברים שהם זוכים זכרונות. ולפני כן אני לא רואה זוכר
מגיל צעיר זה יכול להיות גם לך. אולי אחד הזיכרונות שזה אותו סיפור שסיפרתי לך
על מראש
עד היום. אני זוכר אפילו את הרחוב, את המקור
שרצנו אחריה
הביתה מהר וכדומה.
כמובן שאני זוכר את הבית שבו גדלנו הבית הראשון הזה, ופתח תקווה. כיום הוא כבר לא קיים.
וכדומה,
ועוד מעשי נערות. אבל אתה זוכר, גם
כן. כן, אני זוכר את זה.
גננת שהייתה אולי, אתה יודע, זה גם סיפורים שמספרים אחר כך על הגננת. היא מתה,
זוכרת בעצמך, או זה ממה שסיפרו במשפחה.
הדברים מתערבבים,
אבל לא בצורה מוחשית.
ואחרי כן אני זוכרת את בתי ספר, ואתה בית הספר שלמדתי,
אבל זה כבר בית ספר באבא בי. תגיד להם שמיאמי
חברים מבית הספר וכדומה,
אבל זה לא
אומר ש לא
מגיעים. ואני יושב שמונה,
תשע,
עשר, אולי משהו לא בדסר?
לא
לפני כן
זוכר מאוד מאוד ש
יום אחד
החלטת הוא היו היו שם
חמורה של אנשים ו
ישו קבוצת הגורם
ואז אמרו
שילכו ל
בשנה
שמעת יום וברגל לתל אביב
אל תכנסו. אותם בני דודים שהזכרתי קודם
אחי הגדול
ואני באתי ניסחתי אחריהם.
אני תמיד הייתי
אז באחי ויגש. החלטה קטן ליכלך הביתה.
הגשתי ואז בבידוד הזה, שהיה יותר גדול בשתיים שלוש אומר לנו
אני רוצה שהוא יבוא איתנו
ו לקח אותי תחת חסותו,
ועד היום אני זוכר את האירוע הזה של מישהו,
זכר וכדומה,
אבל כל מיני קבוצות שילדים
חיפושים על עצים
וכדומה,
אבל אני לא יכול לומר או דברים אחרים.
זה אומר שהאירועים האלה של
זה נחרט בך.
אתם גם גדלתי בבית הספר,
אומר
בפתח תקווה.
לא
כן, צרפת כן,
היו ארבעה.
היה איזה סכסוך בין
פתח תקוה בראשיתה עם
הבוקי שק
היה שבט
ערבי.
אל הירקון
הישווה. הם עשו התקפה. אחת ההתקפות הראשונות של
על פתח תקווה יצאו מגנים וארבעה בחורים נהרגו.
אחד מהם היה שמו אבשלום גיסין,
והשמונה נקרא מכבי פתח תקווה. הרבה שנים בשם מכבי אבשלום,
וזה כנראה אותו שם אפשר המופעים בגב שלא מזיז
לסין
היה מבני העיקריים.
היה אחד שם. זאב אורלוב,
שאני זוכר את השם.
היו ארבעה. אני כבר לא זוכר את השמות שלהם
הייתה מציבה ופתח תקווה כל שנה
במוד המועצה. מה, כל ילדי בתי הספר היו הולכים בתערוכה למצבה
והיה שם טקס,
ואחר כך אני זוכר ש אברהם שפירא היה מופיע על הסוס בטקס הזה,
והוא היה די בוץ האגדי.
עכשיו אמרתי שהוא שכח היגר בבית. סמוך לנו ואילו היה לו
בן שהיה אילם
האילם הזה ששמר על הבית. ועד היום אני זוכרת האילם הזה שתמיד אנחנו נשים כאלה בבית.
היי אבא ומגרש אותנו.
הימים הוא לנו בבית.
מאוד מעניין. שם היה עץ האקליפטוס
שהחליטו שיש לו ריח
אקליפטוס לבן שהביאו באוסטרליה.
אני לא יודע אם הוא קיים עד היום,
אז כל מיני אירועים כאלה.
האקליפטוס הזה, אני זוכר מגיל צעיר וכל מיני דברים אחרים בהרבה רחובות ממך,
מארב
המתאים בבית.
אבל אני לא יכול גם לנקוב שנה בדיוק. ומתי
הנוער? מתי אתה מתחיל
לא לתנועת נוער. נכנסתי בעיקר כשהגעתי לירושלים
בפתח תקווה. עדיין לא
בבית ספר עממי. עדיין לא הייתה תנועות, לא כמו שהיום
היו חברות ילדים
מאוד שהיינו חברת הגורם וחברות אחרות
מתבססים על העצים וכדומה, אבל
אבל לא הייתה תנועת נוער, הוא הנוער, והוגנת היתה כשהגעתי לירושלים, ואז הייתי פה גם
לבד. אני לא יכולה לתת
לו שלושים לאורח לשבועיים.
כן,
והמעניין שאז אמרתי זה בבית הספר, בטח כמוני בירושלים.
ואחרי שהגעתי שנתיים יותר מאוחר ב
הגעתי קבע כבר ירושלים לא קבע כי התלמיד בסמינר.
אז פגשתי באחד התלמידים שהיה לבחור שהוא על היום חייב יהיה חיים מלאבד
אבא שלו. פרופסור עזרה, ציון מלווה
הייתי בבית עם כשהייתי השבועיים
בשואת מקור ברוך
והתיידדנו, והכרנו שוב ועד היום אנחנו בידידות
ו נפגשים מדי לפעמים בירושלים.
אבל היום חיים
ב
לפני פרוץ המלחמה.
כן,
מבחינת המודעות ל תמונת מצב, יש הפגנות נגד הספר עליו? בוודאי. כן. אז
אתה זוכר את
אם
יש לך אז מודעות.
אני זוכרת את כל הסיפורים על הספר הלבנים. זה מתוך מה שאחר כך
עסקתי במלחמת העצמאות
וקראתי.
אני אומר לי שאני זוכר גם קטע הפגנות עלייה עברית מדינה
עלייה חופשית, מדינה עברית
בירושלים דראג בחור אחד בעליית קולנוע עדן בהפגנה
אתה יודע, אני זוכר את כל הספר הלבן. אני לוחית זוכר, תעשה, אבל אבל אני זוכר
יותר מכך שכולל שבת
והם אמה, אנא שובו השיחות בערב ואין שבת
ויכוחים נגד האנגלים, האנגלים לצאת למאבק העצל או אצל ההגנה
מי צודק,
ובוודאי אחר כך את עולי הגרדום, את כל מה שכל הסיפורים על. אבל זה הרבה יותר מאוחר.
אז כן, הזכרת את העניין של המאבק. הנושא הזה של
שבתקופת המאורות, הנושא של אב
ההפלגה. בדיוק.
ואני זוכר אתה זוכר את זה? להקרין אבל הגן. אני זוכר גם את כל הידיעות
כשאני זוכר את הידיעה. לא, זה מטושטש.
אחת מאנשי העצל בשעתו
בירושלים, תבנית אחר, רחל רחל חמשוש
נעשה לחיפה וזרקה פצצה בשוק בחיפה ונהרגו.
זה היה ויכוח גדול. עם
וצריך להבין, צריכה להיות הפלגה או לא צריכה להיות הוקאגה,
כולל בצורה של יישובים חומה ומגדל,
ואני חייתי בתוך התקופה הזאת, אבל אני אגיד לך את האמת, אני כבר לא את בטוח היום אני
זוכר לעצמי, הוא ממה זוכר ממה שאני
עסקתי וחקרתי ולמדתי אחר כך, כי אני עסקתי בזה הרבה אחר כך,
אוקיי?
ועכשיו
אתם
לגמרי הויכוח שעבר בבתים, במשפחות בעצם ובה לכי
מספר לך שאותם בני דודים האלה
אחד היה בפלמ ח ואחד היה בא
בעצם,
והיה ויכוחים שיעלו אלו עד השמיים.
היה לי
בן דוד אחר שהיה בבת ים במשפחה והם,
והם שלחו אותו ללמוד. פתח תקווה
היה חבר טוב מאוד שלי היו לאחד מחברי הטובים ביותר,
והוא בסוף צמח באס, אבל לא יודעת כמה שהוא היה ואחר כך נסע לאמריקה,
ואני רק שם בתאונת מטוס
ו
ויש היה הוקי, ולוי שישבו,
הוא החליט לשמוע. אחר כך
אמרתי לך את השם,
אבל
לא משנה.
זה דבר ש היה לי חבר טוב בשם ארי ימיני ופתח תקווה. נהרג בהתקפת העצל
בשעה ביפו,
ואני עוד חבר טוב ממה שגדלנו לך בשם אורי מקלב. משפחה מאוד ידועה,
ירושלים. והוא נהרג ב כיבוש הכפר יהודיה
ב על ידי התקפת העצב.
את כולם אני זוכר, ואחד בנימין קפלן, שנהרג בהגנה
ועוד אחד
כשהיה
טוב ז ל היה שם עירום רוזנבלט שנהרג בקסטל בירושלים
והיה יותר מדי כיתה. אני אחר כך לא ראיתי אותה משנה, אבל 'בין כיתה שלך
כן
ובין ברמלה,
אבל זהו בית ספר עממי. הוא בנתניה פיקד על חטיפת הסרג'נטים,
ואני לא ידעתי יותר. אפילו יודעת להיסטוריה ולא ראיתי אותו כי אני גמרתי עם אמי.
לא היה לי קשר איתם, כי אני בת ירושלים. חמש שנים הייתי מנותק מהם,
אבל הם היו חברים כל כך טובים.
בנימין פחות כי הוא גר בכפר גנים בפתח תקווה. לא בתוך,
לא במרכז העיר,
אבל האריה מיני לאביו היה חנות יין
ודוב ימיני ברחוב הראשי ופתח תקווה בבית הכנסת, ואנחנו היינו קונים שם.
הוא היה חבר
מאוד טוב
בילדות בגיל, בספר עממי
ואותו אורי מקלב גם כן
זה שנהרג בקסטל. אני היה חבר טוב, אבל לא כל כך. השניים האחרים היו ממש
בני בית אצלנו, אבל זה עבר זמן כי
אני הגעתי לירושלים ב
ואין לדעת מה עוד. פרצה בשוהים ושמונת אומרת.
באתי לפתח תקווה בשבתות ובחגים והייתי,
אבל לא היה לי קשר איתם
אז.
לכן במשפחה אין משפחה באירופה. כמעט בעצם.
וכשאתם שומע
העסק מלא בגיל
לשמוע
אומרים שפרצה מלחמה באירופה
שרוצים יהודי או זוכר את
הרדיו. רדיו היה דבר מאוד חזק.
כל שבת קומות ששבת הישיר
המפורסם.
שבוע טוב, שימו אותו,
אבל מה זה היו שומעים את הרדיו היו מתכנסים מסביב לרדיו.
אנחנו ליווינו את את ההתקדמות של
של
הצבא הרוסי לעבר גרמניה. את כל הגנרלים היית קורא עיתונים?
אני הייתי משוגע לקריאת עיתונים
והאיש קוראת כל העיתונים ו
היינו
עוקבים אחרי כל
אחרי כל מה שקורה בעולם בצורה שוטפת, לא פחות מאשר היום.
העניינים הפוליטיים היו מאוד
בדמנו,
במה שמתרחש בעולם.
זה קשור גם
הוא שעל השואה. לא ידענו כמו כרכים, אבל ברגע שנודע וההפעלה והמפעילים,
כן,
והחשש מזה שהגרמנים הגיעו לכאן,
בוודאי כל הסיפור על המשולש ועל הפלמ ח. אבל הזה
שוב אני אומר זאת, אז
אולי להתערב אצלי מה שאני עשיתי הרגע רבב במחקר.
אבל אני
תראה
אחי זכרונו לברכה היה בפלמ ח הדתי
וכדומה, והיה איזה זמן ואחר כך
עניין של הפלמ ח והעצם והליכי.
הבחור הזה שנראה
שלקחו אותו אך קשה,
שמו יהודה נאות
היום חיים, ויש יארך ימים
שאחר כך. מפקד החלטות חיילים בצה ל
היה מפקד חשוב בצה ל שסיפרו עליו יום אחד שהוא התנקש ב
הנציב העליון הבריטי כמה כרוניקל. הוא אמר לי שזה לא נכון,
אבל אבל לא חשוב. סיפרו עליו ותפסו אותו פה בירושלים.
הוא הלך רק עליה. היום
שקאדי שם התנגשות
והוא
כשחיפשו אותו אצל אייטו
הוא ישן אצלנו בבית.
אמא שלי האומנת, היתה אשה טובה מאד.
יוציא אותנו מזה חדר קטן של הילדים ונתנה לו את החדר. והוא העקב
נכנס דרך החלון ויוצא מהחלון
כשהוא חזר מכני. אני זוכר את זה עד היום
כשהייתי בבית. אני לא זוכר
אם הייתי או שמעתי את זה
ב אם איי. אז דבר ראשון לפני שהוא הגיע ל בתוכו, הוא עבר דרך
בטנו בנשק
טוב.
אבל אני מוכרח לתת נשיקה לדודה רבקה
שהיא החביאה אותו.
והוא היה שם ארבע שנים
וחזר ארצה והיה בצה ל והיה מפקד החלטות חולים וכדומה.
ואחיו שוק
המניות היה בפלמה חיה בנגב. כל מלחמת העצמאות הוא נפטר. בינתיים לפני
הוא נקרא גם כן יהושע
שוקה קראו לו
על שם אותו יושע שידבר
כי האמא שלי ו
הם היו קשורים. כן,
אני חושב שג'ימי הוא גם הוא בן דור חלום ג'יבלי
כן, כן, אבל לא הכרתי אותו
כי אני אומר לך אני לא הכרתי אותו
בדור פתחתי לגבי הספר תיכון כי בית ספר פרטי
הכרנו הייתי
מספר על המעבר ולמה זה קורה
רגע
על זה גיל
בסוף עממי
אז רגע, זה נגבתה אותך
מרביץ? עוד תקבלי כן, כן
אחרת בעולם. כן, אני סומך. מה אני זוכרת מצפים
מהבר מצווה
שפילים ג'וזף, העורך דין הזה
במכונית לפחות בביצוע
וכל הפרק העיקרי דתיים כאן דיווח של שיגרום כוחנית,
אבל את המכונית והשאיר החוק
והוא בלע ברגל.
ואם מכובד מאוד, איש עשיר מאוד באים
עם האנשים שלו.
אז אני זוכר את התמונה שהוא בא ל בר ביצוע. אז אני זוכר את הדרשה
ש ש ש אני
היו נוראיים, דרשה. אבל אצלנו אבא שלי, כיוון שאמרו רווחי. ברי זה
נאום.
ואני קראתי את הנאום הזה תודות ומשפחה. איזה מין נאום כזה
ציוני, הייתי אומר במרכאות
בבתים. האחים היו
רבים.
איזה פרק ב
אנחנו בפרשת השבוע ומסבירים אותו כאילו היה
נוהג אחר שאתה
מודל המשפחה אומר איזה דברים אני
היום זוכר
משהו ךיא ברלי לדרשה? איזה קטעים אני יודע
תפילה או משהו אחר.
אני זוכר את זה אחרת. האנשים שבאו, אני זוכר
איך יש עמדו אחר כך לספור את הבוטן, שפות, את
מה הגיע צ'קאל ואיזה מתנות ליום וכדומה. אבל כל דברים מטושטשת.
אנחנו גם עברנו מבית לבית וזה היה בבית אחר, לא בבית שאחר כך היה לנו קשה
לו. המשק של המשפחה.
לא, לא, לא, לא.
אנחנו
עברנו בכמה דירות שחורות, והם באותה זמן יש. האבא שלי עבד אצל העובדים.
אפילו עם ג'וזף כנראה מצב המצב
הכספי היה טוב.
ואז הוא הצליח לרכוש בית קטן
באליה לבית של אברהם שפירא
לנו בית קטן מאוד נחמד בנפילה. כזו
שנדמה לי עכשיו שהרסו אותו וגם עם שכירות. שם.
לא שם הוא קנה איתו.
כן,
כרגע
זה בשבילכם. את
זה פעם הוא היה שם? כן. מתי? זרחה, ממונה לראש.
בואו הרבה שנים. אני
הוא
היה ילד. אתה כבר
כן, כן, כן, כן. חושב שבשנות השלושים הוא היה ראש העיר. מי שיחליף אותו. אגב, כראש עיר
זה היה יוסף ספיר
שהחג אשר חשוב מהליברלים
זה שיושב. ספיר היה ראש עיריית פתח תקווה,
ואז אמר לך זה מפתיע
שסבי היה מהמשפט אדם דתי ומשפטית
בסוף חבר, דווקא
גרבובסקי. זה תרגם את השמונה הארגון.
הוא היה שר חרא, חקר בכנסת.
אז
דווקא הוא התחבר עם אימנו את הפועלים.
זה כן. זה כנראה היה נגד
ספיר, שזה היה הציונים הכלליים.
כן,
והוא היה בדיוק מאוד עם גרבובסקי בגוף
וזהו.
ונדמה לי ש ספיר
דחק את סבי. אני כבר לא בטוח
לתפקיד ראש העיר. ואז סבי עזר לארגו והרגו ודחק
את ספיר ובנייה ראש עיריית בדרכי. גם משם הוא הגיע. חייב להיות חבר כנסת
ביחד, ממנהיגי
תנועתי הפועלים ומפליא וכדומה.
אז זה היה ויש שם
עוד אחד
שאחרתי כבר את שמו
היא ראש עירייה ידוע מאוד בפתח תקווה
במפה,
אבל הוא היה בשנות השלושים ואני חושב
בשנות השלושים
הרבה של יער, מועצה ובזמנו
פתח תקווה הפכה להיות במועצה לעירייה.
אז עכשיו ספר על המעבר לירושלים. ולמה?
מה מוביל אותך?
אני אומר לך שיש
לי שתי סיבות עיקריות
אלף בסתר, כי כבר לא היה בית ספר דתי
תיכון.
תירה כמה בית
הספר התיכון בסדר ידוע. בית ספר אחד האב.
לכן רוב התלמידים האלה שאני החברים לשלי, שהייתי בכיתה
והלכו הלכו אחר כך לתיכונים. אחר כך כולם גם נעשו לא דתיים. כל הארבעה, אלה
שהזכרתי קודם שנפלו
כן,
וההורים שלי רצו לשאול אותנו אותנו לבית ספר תיכון דתי.
ופה יש סמינר מזרחי באושר הזה, המזרחי? כן,
מזרחית, אלא אנחנו היינו מזרחי על אף פעם לא
בבית, היה מזרחי גמור.
אבי גם היה אדם, לא
אמא היתה יותר השומרת, מצורות, קלה כחמורה.
אבי היה אדם יותר מתקדם, אפילו
בנשורת המזרחית,
אבל הוא הכיר גם טוב את סמינר מזרח ירושלים,
כי הוא למד כאן
גם בעצמו. היה מטר בוגרי המחזור הראשון.
היה פה דבר
והזכיר את את המנהל ואת וכדומה.
וגם המשפחה, יקירה.
ואז הם פנו אליהם,
היה סידור שלו היו משלמים שכר לימוד בכלל,
זה היה הרבה כסף, ואני זוכר חתמתי השטרות לשתי בס השטרות.
שש שנים אחר כך
פרטיותה, וזה כבר לא יהיה שווה כלום.
אבל שילמתי את
ימיה. בעצם
יש לו הפנימייה, זה שכר לימוד.
ואז ועל הגור שכרנו חדר בירושלים. בסדר כן,
אז כשאני באתי כבר הכי הגדול היה כאן ואני גרתי איתו
שנתיים אחר כך לחברי כמה
בשנתיים
נזכיר את שמו אשר
ששמו נקרע בין השני של יאשר.
אוקיי,
אז נער בן
ורבע,
והרגע וגברת אני אארח את ירושלים. היא הייתי בגיל,
הם אמרו לי בר מצווה היתה באפריל מאי.
אני מהיר רק ואומר
וביולי
בהלול אני בת ירושלים
והר ופה היה הכי הגדול, אבל כל אחד מאיתנו.
גם כשהיינו בחדר
אחר כך הוא כבר יצא. ואז אני המשכתי לגור בחדר ירושלים.
עד היום שאני לוקח את בני המשפחה ומראה להם את החדר
בבתי. הביטי בגשר, אגרתי הרבה שנים
ואחר כך כשעזבתי, כשהוא עזב. כך אז עברתי אפילו לכמה חודשים למאה שערים וגרתי אפילו
לזה כמה חודשים בשמעון הצדיק ובאיזה כחבר, מתחת לאדמה שאתה משלם. פרוטות שם
והיה לי
קצבה. הייתי מקבל
גשש לראות
שיש לראות הבריטיות
וחודש ומזה הייתי מתקיים בירושלים.
אז פה גורל אחד נקשר עם העיר הזאת.
כן. ואז כממונה הראשונה שחרוטה לך שאתה.
אני חושב שהתמונות האלה שהיום אחד השיא, היה לי עוד חבר
פה בירושלים היום
חבר יצורים רפי וכשל בו מה יש בו,
רפי אילן
ו
אני זוכר שהוא היה גר פה דווקא בקרוב
אצל דוד שלו או משהו, ואני הלכתי משם ברגל אליו
והיינו בשבתות מטיילים. ביום אחד טיילנו בעיר עתיקה,
אנחנו בחופש שושלת ולא ידענו שזה והגענו לכניסה לתוך הרפאים
ונכנסנו להר הבית.
פתאום קפצו מהצד הערבים. היה אסור להיכנס,
צחקו עלינו.
בכיר אנחנו
כל עוד נפשנו
ואסור היה להיכנס ל בכלל הרבה.
אז למשל את התמונה הזו אני זוכר
של טיול בעיר העתיקה. אני חושב שזה היה בשביל
או
משהו דומה לזה,
ואחר כך אני זוכר מתכוו שנות הארבעים אני זוכר הרבה בית.
הייתי לבני עקיבא אחת, הייתי מדריך בבני עקיבא.
אז
השנה אתה מתחיל ללמוד, והלימודים הם
הם הלימודים גם של דעת,
אבל גם לא זה למילים של סמינר כמו של כל שמינהל, כמו סמינר בית הכרם מסר
בבית ספר תיכון לימודים רגילים לבחינת בגרות.
ההורים שלי היו אנשים מכובדים מאוד שהיו פרופסורים ואחר כך
היה ענן לחנוך. ילון, שהיה מראשי
יודע השפה העברית, חבר של עגנון,
הידיד ואולי המדוקדק
החשוב ביותר היה רב. זה וין
רב שתחבר את הג'י כלפי התלמודית.
איש
משכמו ומעלה
היה
וליצור. יהודה אליצור, שכולן על
בני המשפחה, היא שביום באופרה ובנים שלו גם כן פרופסורים
שהטבע. מה זה למדנו טבע
וכדומה. למדנו ערבית.
עברית
פרופסור יהושע בלאו
כולם התנסו רק הפרופסור פרופסור בנימין קלר
שנהרג אחר כך בשיירת
של ג'ראח ולגמרי אותנו. ספרות עברית
כולם אנשים שבאו
בחוץ לארץ והיו
משכילים, ואם היו את האוניברסיטה הם נוסעים לאוניברסיטה. ועובדה שרבים מהם
היו החגב. פרופסורים באוניברסיטה העברית
אומרת זו הייתה רמה גבוהה מאוד של מודיעים. חלו אנוך,
שהיה פדגוגי ידוע. הוא הקים החג על בספר כפר בתיה. בתיה,
אם שמעת על יד רעננה,
כפר הילדים הראשון
היה פה
לפרופסור, למעט
דוקטור. למה
בוף
שהיה מורה. למה קיבלתי ק אני קיבלתי ומה קיבלתי. כעשר
מבחינת בגרות חיצונית.
ולמדנו הרבה. אבל
לפני הלימודים היה כך
אל לחיות. ברוור,
חוקר ארץ ישראל הידוע לי, מלט על גיאוגרפיה לקחנו לטיול.
אני זוכר יום אחד ל רמאללה,
זה כבר בזמנו בהיר.
רואים בשש.
היה
אצל. אז אסרו אותנו את כל הכיתה
והכניס אותנו לכלכלה בוש ברמאללה,
עד שבאו ואמרו לנו ש אמרנו שם
תלמידים ושחררו אותנו.
והוא היה מורה שלנו. הלך לאותו להמון טיולים. אני
ובנו משה ברוור שום פרופסור בתל אביב
וידיד שלי וחבר שלי,
והיה חוקר רציני מאוד גם כן,
ועוד גיאולוגים שהיו אחר כך
לימדו את אותנו
בסמינר. בסמינר עמד ערבה היה
אלף מהם. ליפשיץ חוקר לשון עברית ידוע,
הידיד הכי טוב של עגנון
וקצין האלבום רופא אחר כך ושם מנהל
בעלי
המורים היו, אבל התרוקנתי אדוני, שבית ספר מזרחי למדו הרבה טייגר שעמדו תלמוד
היה אפילו מניין בבוקר שאם היית רוצה לבוא התפלל ומלומדים
וב כבר בשנת המבנה עצמו המבנה עומד עד היום
אפשר מכללת ליפשיץ בירושלים,
אבל
הסכמנו לשמור על שמה
של המוסד. כן, בית הספר. יש סמינר למורים מזרחי. היום זה נקרא מכללת ליפשיץ.
זה ברחוב הלל
בירושלים מול בניין כלל, שם יש שלט גדול
היום לשם המכללה.
הבניין עומד כולו
אוקיי,
אני רוצה לשאול אותך שאלה. השנים האלה
מלמדים אתכם ומתחיל להיות מודעים למה שקורה
ואת הדברים בבית הספר על המצב של העם היהודי, על מה שקורה באירופה
אני לא זוכר. אני חושב שידענו על מה שקורה ברוב
כהיסטוריון. כשאתה רואה את זה דיברו הרבה על זה היה המצב. למה זה כך?
לא ידעו בארץ דו אל תיתן לך, לא יודע,
לא ידוע. שואה יהיה נודע אחר כך. יותר מאוחר
לא ידעו
אם הסתירו את זה או לא הסתירו.
זה כבר ויכוח בין היסטוריונים.
לא ידעו. תראה,
לא ידוע. אני לא
זוכר שהייתי מודע. ריס
תאי במעבר
הייתי מודר בנפאל. עניין של העצב בהליכי בארץ.
אחד מהתלמידים חברים בכיתה, זה כבר כבר מאוחר.
היא היה אצל ולהשתתף באיזו פעולה על הסי איי די.
אף רגע, זה להגיע ל
כן,
אבל אני רוצה לשאול לגבי העניין.
אתה גם במעבר שלך מפתח תקווה לירושלים, רואה הרבה יותר בריטים.
מה כן ברחובות של בחגורת, בסטייט הופמן הזה של להיות. אז
נ
ב. אני רוצה להבין את העניין הזה. המשמעות. אתה מבין
שהערבים יש לך, אתה יודע את ההיסטוריה
של
פתח תקווה. גדלת בעיר זו,
אבל לא ידעתי את ההיסטוריה הלאומית הערבית.
אוקיי, אבל יש
ויש פריטים שהם
מדינה זרה שיושבת כאן
בתוכם
מנדט.
האם
בשנים האלה הם שם?
הנושא הזה של
של הצורך ולהקים מדינה צורך ב לגרש את הבריטים או הצורך ו לכבוש טריטוריה
חי בכם
בתור
נערים. אז בוודאי
כל המאבק נגד הבריטים, כל הרעיון למדינה יהודי
ושתיים שלוש. כן, כי בסדר, אבל אפשר
היה ספר הדבר
מה הספר הלבן ב,
הרי לפני כן ב.
אני זוכר את ההוראות של
אני זוכרת את הסכנה לנסוע בכבישים
כל יום. המודעות, האוזן, רכז. אני רק זה רק במקום הזה, במקום הזה.
התקפה. אני יודע על היישוב הזה, התקפה על היישוב הזה.
גם יישובי חומה מגדל. אני לא יודע אם בהקמה שלהם הייתי, אבל גם שבכמה זה
כבר היה ברור
ואחר כך
משמר השרון, שם לא משמר השרון
רמת
אני זוכר כבר על ידי
טול כרם לקלקיליה.
ההתקפות על היישובים רמת הכובש האלו של בעיקר
לרמת הכובש.
ההתקפות הזה בוודאי אנחנו ידענו
והעיתונים תזכור. אך כל יום העיתונים היו בשחור. זה נהרג, וזה רק בזה נהרג.
ואנחנו חיים הוא על זה.
ולכן
כשבא עניין של
של הספר הלבן
שאין מדינה יהודית,
אי אפשר לגדול קרקעות,
אין עלייה יהודית, וכל העניין של העלייה היהודית, אשר תפיק עטים
ואנשים שבאים אינה והמפעילים, התחיל
להיות ידוע כבר אז. האוניות שמפעיל ימשיכו להגיע.
אנחנו חיינו את היישוב חיינו בצורה חזקה באו. זה בעצם היה
הציר
שעליו אסף כל החיים שלנו
כנערים,
ואמרתי, הרעיון הלאומי היה מאוד חזק
בחוגים שלנו.
וזה לא היו חוגים,
הייתי אומר.
במזרח
כן, במזרחי, בוודאי, בני עקיבא ואני. כשבאתי לירושלים נכנסתי והייתי פעיל מאוד
בבני עקיבא, והייתי אחר כך מדריך,
ועד היום אני פוגש אנשים מאוד מבוגרים, שהם היו חניכים שלי. הוא מזכירים לי את הימים
שהייתי מורה.
הייתי למדתי והייתי חינני. מורים בדרך שם.
אתה זוכר ב
כשאתה שומע
הגיבוי שלהם
אני ממש הפעילות שלו.
תראה, אני לא בטוח שוב אם זה לא בהרבה והסביבה שהבאתי אחר כך במחקר,
אבל אני חושב שהעניין של הליכי
כבר בשביל זה קיים שאני לא.
אני לא יודע אם שטרן, אבל הרי על הגרדום של בית חכים ובית צורי במצרים
למשל.
כן, זה כבר היה חזק מאוד
ומתי. ואני
חושב שאפילו בן יוסף
של שמונה לילות. חשבתי כבר
שלא יושב שזה היה ידוע. טוב, זה כבר לא יהיה. זה עניין בעיתונות בנושא. ומה שפינה
ומה היה שם,
זה לא היה זה
ממה ששאבנו זה היה העיתונות. העיתונות הייתה מלאה עם כל הדברים האלה.
אתה זוכר ששמעת על מרדכי שוורץ
יכול יותר בשם שאני אומר
גם שהוא היה אחד מהשלושה שם?
לא, הוא יפה, איש הגנה.
לא, אני לא. אז אנחנו
אני זוכר שהיה ביקרו הגדול עזב
השלישי שהוא היה בגיל
שלו יכול לקיים משפט, לא למשפט.
ואחד ממני. הרי מה אם זה
כן? אחד
מהשלושה? רק את
בן יוסף בסוף טיילו השניים האחרים
אחד מבלי
שוחרר בגלל שאמרו שהוא לא כל כך שפוי. אני לא יודע מה שימציאו עליו, אבל זה לא זה. כן.
מה זה כל שקורה. אלא אם כי היינו חיים יחד. יתלו אותו, לא יתלו אותו.
גן יהרגו אותו, לא יהרגו אותו. אתה זוכר?
כן, אני בוודאי בעיתונים זה אני לא שומר
אם הייתי ילד. אבל
אמרת שהייתי
בעיתונים. תרמית.
נעשה רגע אחד, הפסקה
זה וי על מי שהיא מתחכם. אז אנחנו בערך היה זה לשתות משהו
או
לא, אני מסתדר עם יש לי פותח את הישיבה.
הוא סוחט אותי. החדש שלך
כן,
אנחנו ב
כן, כן, בירושלים
וגם ומתחילים
בגיל ההתבגרות.
כן. איפה זה פוגש אותך בעניין הזה? אתם אתה
בסמינר זה רק בנים,
לא
בני עקיבא, למשל.
אני הייתי באסם, היה רק בנים,
אבל בני עקיבא
זה היה בנים ובנות יחד.
והיו הרבה בנות שם שהיו חברות ידידות. לא היה
יחסי או משהו קרובים,
אבל חברות. היו לי הרבה
ככה כדוגמא.
ראומה אלדר. השדרנית הראשונה
שזה
הייתה באותה
קבוצה שלי בזה ובדידות רבה מאוד. שנים רבות אישרנו אחר קריד ידידים,
ודווקא היה לי חבר שם בבני עקיבא.
כשלמדתי יחד בקידמה ושמו יש שמואל בג'ינס, כי
אחר כך בזק.
אבא שלו היה מראשי המזרחי, אחר כך אחי, וזה יעקב בזק,
שהיה
ששופט עד היום
שיאריך ימים
ח שנמשה, התחתן עם בת דודה שלי
ואני הייתי עמוד בביתם
והוא היה איתי יחד בקבוצה.
אז רום אמרה ש משה והוא צריך
שמואל מוצא חן בעיני יותר מאשר אני
מציע אחרת.
אז אני נפגעת יד, אז אני יודע, אבל היינו חברים ועוד היו הרבה
חברות,
סמכו שם גם זוגות
לי לו הוא היה שהוא באחד, אבל היינו
היו כמו שהיום
היום לרכיבה נעשה יותר.
אז
יהודים יחד, בנים ובנות.
זה לא היה
משהו שיכולת יותר גבוהה
ממה? החצאיות? כן, אני חושב שאנחנו גם עם מכנסיי בשער.
כן, יש לי אחות שהיא נשארה דתית ואי
הייתה אך בנחל והייתה אחר כך
והיא באן סורים. עד היום המשפחה הדתית ש
מתקדמת מאוד, כל הבנות שלה שירתו בצה ל
ובאיזשהו היום
לקצין גבוה בחיל האוויר, אבל
שישמע
אסתר אסתר היה מבצע. הארי
ובעלה, קוראים לו מושב, ניקו היה מאנשי
עין צורים. עוד לפני כן היה בשבי
ביחד, ככה שכלב יהיה בגוש והיא הלכה אל הנחל שם
והם הכירו
והם עד היום
פעילים.
אנחנו מדברים כל פעם ורואים אותם,
וכל יש לה הבנות בשתי בנות בסעד, ואחד מהם
ובין אמרתי לך בצבא,
אלא בעיה גם בין
מתנחלים בכפר דרום,
אבל רוב המשפחה הם מאוד
מאוד נתונים.
כן,
הזכרת
את
הנושא של
שני להיות במצרים, אבל זה זה קורה.
יושב ראש
ב,
דובר או משהו כזה. כן, נשים באור מאוד כן.
ואתם אתה כבר אז בין
כן. אז הדיון שכן
אני זה אמרת כל הדברים האלה נובעים העיתונות ומה שדיברו מהרדיו וכדומה.
כמובן שאני אחר כך. כחוקר, היא
יודע הרבה על העניין שלו, דברים וכדומה.
אבל אם מבחינתי אני אולי אירוע חשוב, היה זה ההצטרפות שלי להגנה
להגדלה זה מתי
אתה יודע? אני לא זוכר בדיוק, אבל
נגיד אם אתה אומר. אני חושב שבגיל
כבר
יום אחד אמרו לנו יש הגנה
וגייסו
תודה. ועד היום אני זוכר הדרך הקודם על החדר הזה של יישוב ישהו אותה ואת כוח.
ומי שהשביע אותי. היה אדם בשם בויש ריבלין,
שאחר כך היה מנהל הקרן הקיימת,
ואחרי הרבה שנים פגשתי אותו רק כשהייתי בתפקיד ביירון ועושה.
הוא עזר לי בכספים
ועושה
וסיפרתי לו שאני זוכר את ההשוואה להפקות
של הגנה.
והיו עוד כל מיני אנשים שם שאני זכרתי אותו בעת האירוע הזה
היה פה איזה קפה מרקוס בירושלים, קווי גלידה,
ובין הקפה הזה
הוא היה באחד במשאבים. היום יושב בגרמניה, אני יודע.
האחיינית שלו, נדמה לי, היתה תלמידה שלי. אז יום אחד סיפרתי עליהם
והיו עוד. אני זוכר מי הים ההרה
המהמם שלי והבן פי וההגנה
לא היה
מבחינת המזרחי יותר. לא, לא בודאי. עקיבא. הלכו כולם להגנה
בני עקיבא. יעד היה
לעצם ולכי. זה היה ביתר או ברית חשמונאים,
כן, אבל בחבורה הזאת שלכם בירושלים, והיו כאלה שאנחנו לייצב נואני וכמעט שלא,
כי מתקן כי היו בהגנה
ודווקא אחד האנשים שהייתי בה
הגנב, איזה טיפוס מיוחד זה
הוא ידוע גם כן בידי יוכי ברנדס, כתבה עליו בספריו
זה בחור בשם
כל הזמן
מאשרים שבאים
עם
פאות וכן הלאה.
הגשנו הגנה
וממני שאמרתי לך עכשיו, מזל שלי היה שהיה ב
בעצם
כבר זה ממילא. ראשית,
הוציאו אותי מירושלים
ושלחו אותי לחדרה. היה מחסור במורים
בארץ,
ואז אני
מהגנה אני עברתי אחר כך להחיש. אז אתה צריך לספר את זה.
והוא היה והוא היה איתי יחד. אני חושב שבג דנה
וגם בך, איש היה עוד דמות שהייתי בהגנה.
אני לא חושב שהוא יקבע בך איש לא בזה.
בוטון
בזה גורודיש
שהיה אחר כך המפורסם, אלוף פיקוד הדרום,
התחיל בגבעת שאול,
ואני זכרתי אותו טוב.
ויום אחד
הוצאתי בפני קורסים של
מפקדי
צה ל והיה שם איזה אלוף משנה או תת אלוף שיש בו היה גם כן אח של גורודיש.
הוא עד היום קיים,
ואמרתי לא תשרת הכי חיים. הוא זוכר אותי.
וכשהיינו חברים טובים כי הוא היה בגילי, הוא בגילי, בדיוק השפילו אותה שנה
ואני זוכר אותה טוב.
והוא שאל אותו בעבר הוא לא זוכר,
ואני מאמין לו שהוא לא זכר
שיעברו על הבחור הזה אחר כך כל מיני דברים אחרים.
אתה אתה לא זוכר, אבל אני זכרתי אותו
וזכרתי את הבחור הזה וזכרתי עוד כמה אנשים,
ממש עד היום גם כן פוגש בירושלים שהיו איתי אז בך, איש
ובכן, אתה מכיש בירושלים זה
אני חושב ככה, כן,
עכשיו
מעניין אותי אנשים שחיים כאן. מתי אתה
זוכר? גם אם זה קרה אחרי
חושב שהבנת
מה קרה לעם היהודי באירופה.
אתה חייב נולד טבעת, ואתה הבנת את זה.
אתה נגמרה המלחמה ב
אני חושב שנגמרה המלחמה.
אז
מה? אני לא
ואז התחילו לבוא הידיעות האלה על השואה ובעיקר עניין שם מפעילים.
אבל לפני זה הם לא פגשת אף ניצול שואה?
לא, לא יצא לי. אני פוגש. אני לא חושב שהמפגש הראשון
תראה. כן, אם אתה רוצה. ילדי טהרן זה
זה תוך כדי המלחמה.
כן, ילדי טהראן. אני זוכר טוב,
אין לך למה? כי וילדי טראן הגיעו כמה בחורים
ל
אז יכול שכבר גם אז הייתי
הייתי, אני זוכר היטב.
עד אז. היום אני זוכר בחור שבא
מילדי טהרן. שמו היה אריה כל,
אבל ישו חי עד היום הרגע במצבו,
והוא הגיע מילדי טהרן איים לעקיבא, והוא היה בחור מאוד דינמי,
ועשה שם כאילו החג היה ממייסדי קיבוץ סעד
בנגב.
היה הרבה שנים. הוא התחתן עם עם חברה מאותו מבני עקיבא, באותו סניף ירושלים.
רבותיי, קראתי גם כן טוב, הייתה ידידה. היא נפטרה כבר לפני
שנים רבות, והוא ניסה פעם שנייה לי זה
אחד שהכרתי אותה
והוא עמדתי בקשר כי הוא אחר קיימות פעיל בעניין של
יהודי רוסיה.
זה שש שרנסקי וכל.
ואני יום אחד נסעתי, אני קופץ על זה. קונגרס גיאוגרפי
ורוסיה ואז
הפכו אותי
לשליח שלהם.
אז הוא התקשר אליי ועוד אנשים התקשרו אליי
ולקחתי איתי זה אחד בחור גיאולוג שהוא בעצם לא היה שייך ל הכנס,
והוא היה
שותף שלי ואנחנו יחד ל שרנסקי דיטל שרנסקי לבית או
ועוד אנשים. הניקיון משכה את השמות שהעברנו להם כל משרים,
עד שיום אחד קיבלתי בקונגרס פתק את הזרע
ואמרו לי לעזוב מיד את רוסיה.
כבר לא נשארתי לסיור
האחרון,
אז
אני חוזר בזה לסיפור של אריה קארול ולעוד אנשים.
הוא הגיע מילדי טהרן ואז התוודענו מאוד לעניין של ילדי טהרן
והיו עוד אנשים
והם התחילו להסתובב. אז אם אתה
אומר לי מבלי
מש הו אני חושב שילדי טירני,
זה היה
זה גם התאים וזה היה דואר שהביאו אותם אלינו
למרותם של
מחבר עליהם לקלוט אותם
והיו עוד כמה מהם, אבל אותם לא, אני לא זוכר אותך. אני זוכר באופן מיוחד.
אוקיי,
עכשיו לגבי איש ירושלים מציק
היה כבר אימונים בנשק? כן, כן, כן, כן,
לקחו אותנו אפילו למטבחים כאלה.
בקושי הראנו כמה כדורים וכדומה,
אבל אני לא זוכר שהמתמחים ממני, שזה היה אפילו באוניברסיטה פה. מי זה? בטווח
או בכל מיני מקומות אחרים לכל
סנהדריה שם.
תראו את זה אני רוצה להגיד,
הרשו לנו אבל התחילו עם הכפפה פים, אתה יודע,
עם המקלות האלה שמכירים אותם
וכל מי תרגלי ו אקדח פירוק אקדח הלימודים של אקדח לכל זה. כן, עשינו פחד בלובר
וכל זה הסיפור בוודאי
אה
זה לא היה. זה היה אפילו מה שנקרא בושה עם הגנה הדתי,
ויצא ספר אחר כך אל הגן הדתי.
אז היו לי שכתבו את הספר על כך. אני הייתי בושה עם אבל
בחור שעל היום ולירוק כוח. אני חושב יושעו אריאלי, זכרונו לברכה שהיה פה. וזה אומר סם
החיים. ויש פה בחור בשם
אלי זוהר
ליכטנשטיין ליישמו
כשהוא היה
גיאולוגיה, הכרתם
ידידים עד היום,
כשביום בדיור מוגן
הוא היה פעיל מאוד שם, והכרתי אותו מאותה תקופה
ניתק הקשר, אבל כשחזרתי אחרי ירושלים נפגשתי עם כל מיני אנשים,
ו
יש כאלה שחידש איתם את הקשר שיש פה אפליה שם בקשר וכדומה.
אז שאני אומר את המלחמה
אתה מסיים את זה? לא,
לא, אני עוזב. את יודעת, לירושלים עוד לפני שאני בן.
כי אם אני עוזב ובבא
ב
אלף אפשרויות
ואני
אני מדבר בגלל שיש
אפשרות
אני עוזב את ירושלים. ארבעים לשבת האוזן. כן, כן, כן, מעורבים בשאלה
ובמאי
ב,
אני חושב,
כן, כן.
אז אני עוזבת.
ואיזה
ביום נואר.
אז רגע, אז אם כך, אז השנייה הייתי הייתי בזמן הזו כן.
או זורק
אבנים בירושלים, אך איש כן
האם
טוב או שזה יבלבל אך אולי מסתורית
בתור לסבול או לא פה ואני זוכר חמה בעמלם יתחלף השלטון
יש ציפייה ואז מתחיל המאבק של העצם נגד הבריטים
ואת זה אני זוכר היטב. מה אתה אומר?
כן. טוב אתה
תנועת המרי זה היה אך לקח פיצוץ קינג דייוויד לא הייתי מאושר אם כבר
כן
למה זה
ביוני?
למה לא היית?
אז אולי כן הייתי כן. אתה לא זוכר? אני לא זוכר את היורה. זה פחות אולי בעיתונים,
אבל מה שאני זוכר כן. זהו האישי
כשאני אתן לך
אמרתי לך.
בכיתה שלנו היה בחור אחד שהוא בינתיים נפטר. שמו היה דוד
בונאוונטורה בונוונטורה, הפרופסור לפסיכולוגיה.
הוא החליף את שמו לאשר היא
הוא יחקה, דיקן הפקולטה למדעי הרוח.
הוא היה חבר הכיתה שלי.
והוא כנראה
היה בעצם אנחנו כמובן לא ידענו.
והייתה הפעולה הראשונה של האצל בירושלים
על פיצוץ בניין הבולשת. הסי איי אי
שם בכניסה למגרש הרוסים
יש שם עד היום שרט ואז רק בחור בשם אשר
בנזימן. אולי כתוב שם
השם שלו זה היה
יכולה לייעץ אל הראשון.
ומחר בבוקר אנחנו לא ידענו שום דבר. פתאום ב
בשבע, שמונה בבוקר, כשהיינו שם,
אופי המשטרה
ואת
והתחיל לעשות חיפוש של שלו בכיתה.
ואני כבר הייתי אז בהגנה בך, איש
תגיד, אתה יכול לאכול בזמן.
והיה לי בבית כל מיני עם מפות וכל מיני תעודות וכל מיני מסמכים,
והם אמרו שמישהו אומר שהם הולכים אחר כך לעשות חיפוש בבתים גם כן.
אז אני איכשהו הצלחתי להתחמק ואמרתי לאותו חבר שמואל בזאק
אני ארוץ הביתה ואני אזרוק לך מהחלון
את מה שיש לי בבית.
הצלחתי להגיע לחדר ולא ציינו את כל היישוב. רשימות של
כל מי שהיה בזה בחדר נביא. זרקתי לו את זה מהחלון. אני זוכר היום את התמונה ואת המקור,
והוא חיכה שם. לקח וברח
איך שזרקתי. דפקו בדלת ונכנסו שני שני אנשים
לעשוץ לחיפוש ועשו חיפוש שלי בבית,
לקחו את המזרון במזרון ועצובה לקחת
איזה חלק קשה.
והיה שם איזה אחד תחת עץ. אני לא יודע מה שהיא נדבקה על המזרון הזה.
אז הם חתכו,
והעץ היה חיפוש. הם הלכו
ואחר כך סיפרו לנו שמחפשים את
דוד
בונאוונטורה.
יום אחד,
כשכבר הייתי
בשבת בחדר, נסעתי בעורף
ביום אחד
עולה על אוטובוס. אני רואה אותו יושב בשורה האחרונה. בסוף
הוא לא ראה אותי. ואני לא ראיתי הפתוחות,
הוא עדיין היה כאן. זה היה אומר לי בזמן הבריטיים.
אחר כך סיפרתי לו. הוא ניסה להכחיש
את האירועים, אבל אנחנו לא חשוב. זה מאה אחוז נכון?
הוא היה בעצם הוא נפטר בינתיים.
וחבר טוב שלי. אחר כך
פרופסור להיסטוריה ו לקלאסיקה בירושלים, באוניברסיטה העברית.
דיוויד אשר היא אז אני זוכר טוב
מהעצב
ואחר כך הכרתי עוד כל מיני אנשים
פה בירושלים, וסיפורים
עוד
לפני לפני הסביבה של ירושלים. עוד תמונות חרוטות לך בתקופת המנדט
בירושלים, כי לימים אתה עוד
תחקור את זה, אבל
יש לך כבר מספיק. אנחנו הייתה לו מספיק לחקור את שינוי תנאי,
מישהו אחר.
לא אני.
אני הייתי. אז הייתי ב,
אחרי שאני זוכר כל מיני פעולות שלנו
באותו הזמן שהזכרתי לך,
נהרג אחר כך בהתקפה לקסטל
בירושלים.
אחר כך פגשתי במשפחה שלו
ואמילי, שיהיו חיברה, נטש ביחס
או ידי דמות בולטת בירושלים.
בן זה בגלל דתי וכדומה.
אבל הכרתי עוד
תראה, הייתי מסתובב בחוגים האלה ומאשרים שמיים. יש בתי כנסת, אנשים
כל בלי דמויות, אבל אני לא חושב משהו מיוחד ש
חשוב וכדומה.
ואיזה עיקרון
לכותל ולהר הבית הצעד האחרון לעדכן את הילדים.
הילדים היינו הולכים לכותל בדרך, כך דר' הבית לא נכנס. ומה
יצא לך? להיות מי
ביום כיפור פעם?
לא, לא, לא הלכתי לדברים. כן, יודע מה? לא, לא שמעתי על זה, אבל לא הלכתי לזה.
לא הלכתי לזה
לטיולים. יצאתם
או יצאנו להמון טיולים? כן. אז בואו את הארץ. כן, כן, כן. בוא נראה זה דם
תישאר. כן, כן, כן, אני זוכר. אפילו את המשקיע, בסדר?
אני יכול לספר דבר אחר? אני
הייתי הייתי
ביום העלייה
להקמת
ש
העצורים.
היה
היה בראש היה כפר עציון,
משואות יצחק
היצורים ו רבדים.
אני לא יודע אם זה מעסות יצחק כהן פצועים,
וכי הוא שכולנו להישמר ושל השדות ידיים כאיש
חומה ומגדל.
כן, כן.
אז באחד היה אני חושב שזה היה
עין צורים, אני לא בטוח. העצורים אולי אפילו מסורות. יצחק שגם
כמה חודשים קודם
כיסו את כולנו. לך
בכתיבה, הוא הכיש
ויצאנו לדבר הזה.
עכשיו אני גם זוכר טיולים לבית סעדה, שהתעלולים בצדה. והיינו הפילים למסעדה
בכל הסיפורים על בצדה, וטיולים למצדה
ובים המלח ו
וכל הדברים האלה, שזה עוד עוד לפני
בטיולים, הרבה
שם עליה רטוב במערת התאומים, לכל הדברים האלה הולכים לנחל שורק.
הרבה טיולים לבדי.
כעת אני חושבת שהם אבל אני כבר לא זוכר אותם למסע, ואני מרגישה שאין אפילו טיול.
ועוד באותה תקופה של הזה.
אמרתי לך שהאמרה וראלף יול ברנר
ידוע היה
אני זזה
בסדר זה ולוקח אותם. קח אותי. ואני חושב ש שאני
בסדר. המצב
בשאלות.
ואתה אומר שאסור את כל הכיתה בטיול ברמאללה,
אז אנחנו טיולים. זה היה שיגעון של אותם הימים.
היתה אז את האוכלוסייה הערבית.
מה?
מה חשבת על תמונת מצב.
אני אגיד לך שלא חשבנו הרבה. אז הדברים האלה
תראה, הראש היה שלילי, כי הייתם תירה באחד העצמאות. לא ידעתי מה יקרה,
אבל לא חשב שהוא שוהה. לא,
לא, לא, לא, לא, לא, לא חשבנו שהוא
תראה,
אה,
אני קצת הכרתי את הערבים לעבודה של אבא שלי, אבל ככה וזה עבד במשרד שלה,
אפילו ג'וזף טפילים. יוזף כזה
בין העסקים שלו. עסקת רכישת קרקעות.
כן,
להיות. ואולי אולי בשביל זה לקח את אבא שלי אליו לעבודה.
אבא שלי ידע ערבית
על בוריה,
כי כן, אבל כנראה אני לא יודע. בנערות
שמפעיל שכל הערבים
רק שרון, כנראה לספרות.
בניגוד לי,
והוא ידע טוב ערבית,
אז הוא היה מביא אפילו כל מיני ערבים ו אלינו הביתה, ללול.
יש דברים שהם היו נתקעים בתל אביב. היה מאוחר
ניסוח כזה לחזור לדברים שלהם,
והם היו מביאים לנו מתנות אבטיחים.
אני זוכר עד היום הבית היה מלא עם האבטיחים.
אחד ראשי נדמה לי
וידענו.
אני לא ידעתי ערבית, אבל
הם היו נחמדים. הם שהם ידעו כמה מילים מערבית.
אז מצד אחד האל יחס חיובי לערבים, כאנשים, כבני אדם
ופגש בך.
אבל מצד שני
מאורות
הרצח של יהודים
בכל מקום הכרתי את רמת הכובש והכרתי עוד מקום שיודעים
זה היה נורא. כל יום העיתונים נפתחו,
זה נהרג וזה נראה
לאט.
אז
היה איזה יחס שזה
ומה שקרה אחר כך זה בעצם
אני. זה אני אומר גם מיוחדת. מחקר הערבים נעלמו מהתמונה.
שמעתי. שואל
אחרי הספר הלבן איפה ערבים?
אין ערבים.
הערבים היו חשוב.
היו התמונה חזק
מ המרד הערבי מאוד של שם בשביל
אישה
עד
ספר הלבן בספר, אבל בעצם הם השיגו את
כל מה שהם עושים
עכשיו. חאג' אמין אל חוסייני, המופתי
הלך להיטלר,
לגרמנים
היא
ראשית, עלי אל כילאני בעיראק
דיברו. אני זוכר שדיברו הזה
שהגרמנים הורידו פה צנחנים ערבים,
חגר. היה סיפורים על גב ביום, לא יודע
חסן סלאמה
שייחד מבחן מפקדי הכנופיות
קרוג ג'יי, שהיה עוד מפקד, כתוביות גם בראש.
אז כל הדימוי של הערבים היה קשור השווים, הנאצים,
שפה נוצר מאבק כי
התגייסו לצבא הבריטי התגייסו. הבריגדה
היה ביקור הגדול מתגייס לצבא הבריטי. לא נתגייס לצבא הבריטי.
זה לא רק בן גוריון אומר את זה,
היה ויכוח גדול
ו בפלמ ח או לא הפלמ ח והצבא הבריטי בעצם הכירו את הפלמ ח בהתחלה.
אז בוא, שכן הכרעת חזק. זה המאבק עם הבריטים
והבריטים הרי הבטיחו. אני זוכר את זה
בשיחות בית
שהרבה את מוריסון, שהיה שר
בשר
אדם חשוב מאוד
במפלגת הלייבור.
הוא היא דיבר על טרנספר.
כל הרעיון של להחליף אוכלוסייה
לא במג אנדי
או מי ישראלים קיצוניים.
הלייבור, מפלגת הלייבור אקטע את הרעיון שאם תקום פעם פה מדינה
יקחו את הערבים.
הביאו אותם לעיראק בעיראק עשינו הרבה מאוד יהודים יביאו אותו יודעים לישראל
זה רעיון. אפשר למצוא את זה במקורות
ואנשים מזכירים את זה. היום
ליבו היה פרו ישראלית. הם הבטיחו דברים כאלה
וכולם כיוונו שתתגבר המלחמה
ואפילו שביצ'ר שבגלל שני
תראה
הבליצקריג על אנגליה את זה חיינו גם כן להפצצות על אנגליה
יום יום. ואת
ותתלה ואת כל זה
לא ידענו את השואה, אבל
היית לב
תורת הגזע שלו והאנטישמיות הייתה ידועה. זה כבר התחיל
ועליה הגרמנית של
היו הדברים ידועים
מזה יתלהב.
אז לא ידעו את ההיקף שלי של
את הגזים,
אבל זה ידעו. אם קר לך, אתה רעב.
אז
כל תעצום את הערב הפכה להיות העניין שהמאבק נגד הבריטים.
האם זה מוצדק רצח לעוד מורים ב בזה אף אחד לא ידע
מה שהוא היה מאוד מועיל ולומר לו מצוין
האם זה מוצדק
ואחר כך לתלות סטודנטים שדבר ב שאתם
שיותר מאוחר.
האם זה
גרונר?
אולי לגדול צריך הלילה
ל
להודות או לא להודות וכל ההופעה שלהם
עכשיו
הייתי מאוד קרוב לכך.
היו עורכי דין
שטיפלו והגנו על כל
הנאשמים האלה. אפילו גם
להיות ואבא שלי היה קשור
לעורכי דין. הידיים קשור.
זה היה שלבים. בהתחלה הוא עבד יותר אצל הפעילים, ג'וזף רק פחות, אבל תגיד, אם
כן אז הוא הוא הכיר את כל עורכי הדין האלה.
הוא היה גם אוהב לספר סיפורים, להראות כמה שהוא חשוב.
אז הוא היה מספר כל מיני סיפורים על עורכי דין הזה.
ואעניש את יהודי, לך זה נגמר. נדמה לי.
הוא אומר שהוא מכיר אותו אישית
וקבלי את זה. כמה.
אני אומרת
אז
הכל. המשפטים האלה.
היה משפט של ריקלין וסיר קידן הנשק
שהם
שניים שתפסו אותם, שהוא נשק של ההגנה.
משפט מאוד ידוע.
אז כל המשפטים האלה וכל המאבק הזה. זה היה.
היינו הזה, גדלנו על זה. אני אומר
לו העניין שהשואה לא.
לכן גם כשהייתי באה לשבת הביתה, אז על מה היו מדברים יום שישי בערב?
והמשפטים שהיו על הבריטים וכן הלאה. לך ג ש באכזבה
של דיבור
זה ובבין נקי בעיה,
והיהודים והכעיס שלהם חשוב לקב בכיס.
אז התחילו כל ההשמצות על הבריטי ועל הבריטים, על הבריטים.
ושוב אבא שלי ראה את עצמו כמומחה לפריטים.
אז התחילו כל מיני
הסברים בוויכוחים
בבתים דתיים. אני לא יודע. אצלנו היום, שישי בערב, זה היה יום ש
הגג היה מתפוצץ.
אה,
והתחילו גם ויכוחים ההגנה והעצם ולכי.
אנחנו היינו כבר יותר קרובים להגנה
בבית.
נשמע גם ברוכה או הכשירים. בני משפחה שיושבים ל אצל
העצם. צודק. הגנה צודק. כן. לא.
אז זה חיינו. אבל
אני לא יכול להגיד על השואה ואחריה באו האירועים האחרים.
אבל איך הגענו? הגענו לזה שגם בירושלים זה היה הדבר החשוב.
כן,
מספיק עם התקופה הזו.
זה מאוד מעניין. מה שאתה רואה. זה חשוב לי
כי ריקה,
כי רגע
כדי להבין את התקופה. כן.
אז אז אתה עושה. אז
תן לי רק שוב, שלמרות שאני לא הבנתי את הנסיבות, למה עכשיו אתה עוזב את ירושלים?
כי היה מחסור במורים
בבתי הספר. הבמאים בארץ. אתה בן, ג'ס,
אני פחות אני בן.
וברבע
מהרגע
כן,
וחצי, נגיד
ואז מודיעים
שכל אדם שהוא למד בסמינר בשנה החמישית תעודת בגרות יש לך כבר.
אתה צריך
רק לקבור את לימודי ההוראה, שהיה בעיקר לימודים
ניסיוניים. הייתה צריך לאיזה בית ספר וללמד וכדומה.
אני רואה. בדקתי. גם אתה יכול
להפסיק באמצע שנת הלימודים החמישית,
ללכת לבית הספר, ללמד ותקבל את תעודת ההוראה שלך
בגלל שאתה המחסור.
ואז יום אחד באו אליי ואמרו, יש משרה בחדרה,
המורה ובהריון לא מוצאים למלא מקום.
אם אתה מוכן לבוא,
זה אני אומר לך, זה כבר היה היה נוער, משהו דומה לזה.
אם אתה מוכן לבוא בארה
ב?
כן, סוף. אולי דצמבר.
אז רגע, שנייה, סליחה. ברשותך
לפני שנגיע ב
איפה היית? ב כ ט בנובמבר
בירושלים.
מה? זאת
אני זוכר את ההפגנה? אני יושב באסון את היהודי שרצו כולם לראות את גולדה
שהוא. אני לא זוכר
אם זה לא מתערב לי
בזה. אני חושב שכן. כשרצתי לשם הלכנו לרחובות,
או שאנחנו הוסיף בני עקיבא
ורקדנו כל הלילה.
אני לא זוכר בדיוק, אבל הייתה שמחה גדולה. זה אני זוכר.
הבנתי.
אני חושב שאפילו שמעתי ברדיו
את
הטיס ואנו ובשתי וכל דברים אחרים.
זה כן, זה הייתי פה,
כן,
אבל אז
לא, לא. סליחה. ואני אומר, אני טועה, קוואן לא ולא. לא הייתי
כתבנו ומיוזע.
זה סוף
לו
לא אני טעיתי הזה יודע שאני מקבלים אומר כבר לא. הייתי בירושלים,
הייתי בחדר. אני חושב
על זה. ינואר. אז יכול להיות שלא
הגעת
ללמד
בינואר?
כן.
טוב.
כמה זמן נותר לבדו את מלחמת העצמאות הראשונה וחצי על מלחמת העצמאות?
אני
לא
בואו נגדיר את זה. מלחמת העצמאות
בשלב הראשון אחרי קרטל בנובמבר.
לא, כבר ב
הגעתי לכאן' לחדרה, אפילו בשלב ארבעים. יש אפשרויות. כן.
אז זהו. אוקיי.
אם זה
וחצי הזה,
או אולי אפילו בסוף
הנושא הזה של תנועה, אז
אבל
עד אז, אין בעיה קבועה.
אבל למרחקים, ואז
נגיע לחדר הזה. לא, לא. אני זוכרת דווקא את חדר. אני זוכר עד היום,
חיים מאוד לעניין הזה.
אני
כי זה היה שם.
ואז ואני הסכמתי לצאת
ויצאתי
והגעתי לבית ספר תחכמוני
בחדרה
שהיה בספר דתי.
והיה שם כמה מורות מאוד נחמדות,
שאחת מהם, באמת
או
היתה בהריון, יש שקע לעבוד על מישהו.
הם קיבלו אותי מאוד יפה.
יש שם גם בשלי מורים. והוא
מנהל שאני זוכרת לשם המשפחה
ברוחי.
ואני ילד.
הייתי בן
והיא והרבע וחצי
הם קיבלו אותי.
אבל היה לי קשה מאוד,
כי
אני באתי
לכיתה
לגימה על דלה
ומה אני יודע? והילדים הייתם בינינו שיגעו אותי.
עכשיו זה
ילדים בני חדרה זה לא על ישיר?
לא, לא. בסדר. זה אסלת ושממנה של
האוכלוסייה
שלו. לא שהדתיים בחדר
היה בספר דתית אך כמוני.
אבל כמו פה מזרחי פועל מזרחי כאלה.
זה היה אחד הבורא בשם נויהאוס. אני זוכר
מודיעין שאני זוכר את השמות שלהם עד היום
חיה המורה היתה טובה אחת
והם באמת היו נחמדות. זוכר? אחד הפגישות השונות
שרטטו יש לי
פרופיל מאוד עם אף מאוד וציצים. ציור של פרופיל
לדון לי מתנה.
אבל
אני מוכרח להגיד שלא הצלחתי בהוראה
כי לא היה לי את הניסיון וילדים, אתה יודע, שיגעו אותי
ו
בסך הכל התבשרתי אליהם. הייתה חצי שנה
די טובה,
ואכן כך המורה חזרה.
ואז באו ואמרו לי אתה יכול לקבל משרה מלאה בין ישיב
שמושב תימניים,
והכרתי כבר
את הסביבה,
כי אחד האנשים
בהכרח
ידעתי. הייתי
בחדר עם כמה בחורים,
אחרי השמוק יקשה עליהם משפחה והוא
מאפייה. ושלושים יום אחד אומר בוא ניקח שני סוסים ונרקב, לכפר הרואה.
ואני זוכר עד היום בתל רפש
כשאני רוכב
סושה
לא ידעתי קיבלת שקם בדיוק אף בלי כלום, ואחר כך כאב לי פה.
השתגעתי
והגענו לכפר הרואה בחייל. בקושי חזרתי. והיה עוד אחד שאחר כך פגשתי אותו פה בירושלים.
הרבה זמן. שנים
ידיד שלי הושהה שהחריב את שם המשפחה שלו.
כלום
לא שמעת טוב,
ביקרתי שם גם תלמידות שיהיו בכיתה ז
'כיתה ז ינחית
שאפילו אחד מהם הייתה כאילו חברה שלי, אחרי כמה זמן
ו חלומה,
והרי יחסים מאוד מצוינים שם.
אבל אם אשיר
לא, זה בחדר
מדבר. בטח כמוני. והם פנו אליך גם בהגנה בחדרה.
לא, לא, אני חושב שלא. אני
לא רוצה שתהיה לו זה עוד לא היה זה
הקרטל בנובמבר תופס אותי כבר בלהשיב, אני חושב.
אז
כן,
כי אוקטובר
אני מתחיל לקבל ישיר.
אז אתה זוכר את הלילה הזה?
אז אני עכשיו זוכר שזה היה כנראה אני לך מקיש קרה
אבל אז
אני יצאתי לחופש לחודשיים, וזה עוד היה
מאוד לא היה שום דבר
בלי שהיה הפעולה הזו של הפרדסים. אם אתה יודע שאמר
באיזה בית קפה שהרגו.
ו
בספטמבר,
הציעו לי להתחיל בראשון לספטמבר, התחלתי לעבוד בין ישיר שנת הלימודים של כן,
כן, כן, כן,
כן,
אבל
ראינו עד שבעצם התחלנו
שלושה מורים. ואתה, איזה
מורה,
איזה חטא אתה מלווה,
אני מתחיל. אני יושב כאן שוב בגין הולדה ללא משהו דומה לזה.
ואת זה אני זוכר טוב מאוד. המורה דווקא איתה, גם כן בפתח תקווה.
עד היום
בעלה יחד, הפרופסור לבער. היינו ידידים אישיים, אפילו חברים.
מינואר
שיגרה בשעות בית עתיק, ושהוא, מהפרידה,
כיהן
רק עכשיו. הייתי אחד ולבר
מעלה כבר נפטר מזמן
והיינו רדידות שהם שניהם הרבה שנים
ועוד היו שם. ושתי המורים
היו אחד מזרחי, יעקב מזרחי מזכרון יעקב ושלי
יודע או כל עד היום.
הו רון, אני חושב שמו
אחרי באיזה מקום אין לנו קשר,
אבל אנחנו החלטנו שם לגור בכפר הרואה
קיבל כדי אשיב
לו היתה חברה בערב
וזה אם אס. הם התחילו עוד קודם. מזרח התחילו לפני שנה, שנתיים.
אני גם יודעת,
ואני באתי והשכרתי חדר בבית, בכפר הרואה,
והיינו הולכים כל בוקר
יחד
לבית הספר וחוזרים אחרי השיעורים יחד ברגלי. חשש
ברגל עשרים דקות
בערך ככה
ולכן
אקבל בנובמבר תופס אותי בכפר הרואה
ואני חושב שמה ששמעת,
הריקודים לשמחה וכל זה הם רוצים לשבת היה מוצאי שבת זה בבית הכנסת החברה שבתוכה
ובכבוד מבואי כבר גייסו אותי מחדש עם הלחי שולט
וזה לא לחישה
שמירה על היישוב היו עושים בלילה לשמור וכן על
ידי מיד
יחי
ספטמבר
זה היה ספטמבר
אז כתבתי אפילו ואומר תופס אותנו שם
ואז זה השנה הראשונה של הלימודים
ו
ואני ממשיך שם
בשנה הזו שעליה מלחמה אחר כך
אני מחלק את הזמן ואחר כך אני ממשיך שם עוד שנה חוזר בעוד שנה
ואחרי אני בירושלים אולי אני אפילו מבלבל, אבל
אני רוצה לשמוע את היתה אולי אפילו הכל הקדם בשנה ואפילו ב
יצאתי כבר להם
לא משנה מה. לא משנה אצלי ללמד את זה. בסדר. זה בסדר. כן.
זה
מה זה
והרווח
מסר. ואחרי כן
עכשיו
אחרי הקפה בנובמבר בעצם מתחיל
התנועה בכבישים כבר בעייתית.
לא? כל כך פשוט.
אתה זוכר את המתח הזה של
להיפגע? לנסוע באוטובוס?
לא,
אני לא זוכר את זה.
אמרת את המאורה הראשון שאני זוכר. זה היה
במאי שאנחנו עומדים בצומת יש עד היום כביש
שנכנס לכפר הרואה אם אתה יודע מהכביש הזה
שם בצומת, אנחנו עומדים
בודקים מי נכנס לכל האזור הזה של גבעת חיים
בכביש הצר של ביקורת.
ואז זה. ואז אני רוצה לשאול אותך שאלה. באמת עכשיו? כן. בגלל הזמן שאנחנו ניתן
לומר
הרחק עשק בנובמבר,
אני שואל כן.
כדי לנסות להבין את התקופה
מתי בעצם
לשנתיים
מסתכל מלחמת העצמאות, מתי מתחילה מחט העצמאות? יום אחרי כ ט בנובמבר
או ב
למאי?
איפה ההגדרה? בסדר
אל הפלג לך אני לא כל כך מייצג,
כי טרי של קפה דומים, אבל הוא תפס אותי באיזה כפר וזה מהלך
כחוקר. כחוקר. אין ספק
שקפטן בנוגע
ובהרבה לא חמש.
אני לא מקבל את זה כמו שהיום כמה חוקרים צעירים. אני גם כתבתי על זה
כשמנסים לחלק את מלחמת השחרור
לשתי שני חלקים
החלק שהיה
עד הקמת המדינה, חמש במאי והחלק אחרי הקמת המדינה.
אני חושב שיש פה שגיאה היסטורית גם כן. למה אני לא מקבל את זה?
כי אלמן המלחמה לסבא
המלחמה הינה סבא. אם תקום מדינה יהודית או לא תקום מדינה
זה כל הסיפור היה
הערבים והיא להיכנס להרצאה היסטורית. אני אז
יכנס
בתקופת המנדט ואני אספר לך על עניין של ועדת החלוקה.
חלוקה. כל הסיפור מתחילים בוועדת פיל.
כל הסיפורים אתה רוצה מתחיל מהצהרת בלפור,
שמה שהתחלתי לתת שם בהרצאה.
אני מציע שנניח את זה ואז ניתן לך פעם
הרצאה.
זאת אומרת כל הסיפור של המלחמה היה
האם תקום מדינה יהודית או לא תקום מדינה יהודית.
עכשיו,
אולי מבחינה ערבית אפשר קצת לבוא ולהפריד
ולהגיד
שבהתחלה לחמור הערבים הפלשתינאים ואחרי התחילו מדינות ערב,
וזה גם לא מדויק,
קאוקג'י שזה היה
ערבים במים. בחוץ שבאו מתנדבים
דרוזים
שבאו בקרבות רמת יוחנן,
באו ולחמו כאן,
זאת אומרת
מדינות ערב סיעור לערבים הבקו עם עבד אל קאדר אל חוסייני שנהרג בקסטל,
הובא, מבהירות. והוא נשלח, מבהירות וכן הלאה,
כאילו
זה לא לתמיכה של מדינות ערב.
הם לא נכנסים, אבל מי לעוד במדינות ערב אפשר לבוא להפחיד, אבל מבחינת
היישוב היהודי
במאי הקמת המדינה הוא לא שום דבר. זה אמצע המלחמה.
הבחורים שנפלו בקסטל
ובמבצע נחשון
הם אותם לוחמים שנפלו בדגניה וחגג במשמר הירדן.
פה לא נוצר שום דבר. זה שבתל אביב קמו והכריזו
בעצם היא.
מדינת ישראל לא הייתה צריכה לקום אחד ב
במאי.
לפי תוכנית של היה
מדינת ישראל הייתה צריכה לקום רק בראשון ליולי,
ובחמש שלמה יצר להתגבר המנדט הבריטי
והיה צריך לבוא עם לוועדת ביצוע, והאומה צריך לקבל את השליטה.
זה
תפקיד. הרגע
התחלתי שם לארצות האלה ולא גמרתי. ואני מרצה על זה עכשיו
די הרבה, מפני שלדעתי אפשר להבין
כי הכל
וזה מתחיל,
לדעתי במידה רבה בהצהרת בלפור ולא בתקופה העותומנית
ועכשיו יש לנו איזה קבוצת חוקרים ביד בן צבי
שקמתי נקרא חוקרי ירושלים,
ורק בשבוע שעבר, ביום ראשון אותה אביו החלל. מי שישבה הביא את המסמכים.
יש אגב את כל המסמכים, את הצהרת בלפור, את המסמך ארוורה נובעים וניתחנו את הדבר הזה.
משם זה מתחיל הסיפור וצריך להבין גם את הערבים
הערבים. ראו בהצהרת בלפור ש
שאני הולכת לקום מדינה יהודית והם
לא יהיו רוב
וזה משחק
וכדומה,
ולכן היא כבר
אמורות ערפאת. או יותר נכון בשלושים
שאני ג'ון ג'ונס אור.
הוא כבר
רצה לעשות ספר לבן ולתת להם
עצמאות
והם פחדו מהעלייה היהודית ולכן אפשר להבין אותם
עכשיו ב
כ ט בנובמבר. קפטיין לובר זה השיא של זה.
ואז
מתחילה המלחמה והם אומרים לא,
וכשהם רואים שהם לא מצליחים עם
התושבים קוראים
כל מדינות ערב, אומרות
שלא צריך להקים את
מדינת ישראל ב
במאי. זה לא החלטת האו ם.
תבין את הנשיים הם אומרים
המדינה צריכה לקום. הראשון ביולי.
אתם מפירים את החלטת היום, ואתם מכירים את המדינה בחמש ב
במאי.
אם תקימו את המדינה ב
בבית
אז אנחנו נפלוש ונשמיד את המדינה הזאת עכשיו ישי בגיל
הזה שלא אמרנו בתעריף, כך הם טוענים.
אבו מאזן אומר עד היום לא אנחנו הפרנו את החלטת החלוקה של האו
ם.
אני לא תומך בהם, ואני מאוד בדעה שאין לו.
אבל תבין מה הטענות שלהם.
הם טוענים ואומרים
איפה ואומרים בוא נעזור שם. והם היו כבר ויתרו פעם בואו נחזור לגבולות
בואו לעזור לגברים.
מה הם עשו עכשיו בקטטת בנובמבר?
למה בחרו אותה כ ט בנובמבר? זה אומרים
לפי החלטת היום צריכים לקום מדינה יהודית ובניה הפלסטינאית.
אנחנו מגיעים הנה הפלסטינאית
עכשיו. אז הם טענו
לא הערבים הפלשתינאים,
אלא מצרים וירדן, עיראק וסוריה
ו ערב הסעודית. כל חמש מדינות ערב שהוא דברו
צריך. הבריטים צריכים להיגמר. הוא צריך לקבל פה את השלטון.
הוא צריך להעביר את זה שהוביל
היום לא היה.
האמריקאים נסוגו מתוכנית החלל. חלוקה
אוסטין נציג שלהם. כמה מה
תוכנית החלוקה לא ברת ביצוע, אי אפשר לגשם.
אנגליה
לא הצביע בעד הקמת במדינת ישראל
וחדרי להימנע.
ופה זכותה הגדולה של בן גוריון שמביא אמר.
אין ברירה,
האנגלים עוזבים. אנחנו צריכים להקדים ולהכריז על הקמת המדינה.
והיו עשרה אנשים במינהלת הים
והיה ויכוח והיו
ארבעה אנשים
מהחשובים. שפירא, ראש המעבדה של היום,
בלי רמז שפרינצק אני כבר לא בטוח ב שמות
שאמרו לו להחריש המדינה זה מסוכן. אנחנו לא נעמוד דגל של חמש מדינות ערב.
ואז הסיפור ישן. בן גוריון דפק על השולחן
ולוי אשכול
תהסס.
טבח בו, והוא קיבל שישה נגד ארבע.
זה לא יופיע בספר, כי
לא ירשו רק לפרסם את זה, את זה.
ואז הוא נעשה התשובה השנייה ו פה אחד החליטו לדבר הזה. בכל הספרים כתוב
שהם פרקליט. אבל היה ויכוח גדול
והם פחדו
ושאלו את ידין מה אתה אומר. מה הסיכויים שהמדינה הזו אמר פיפטי, פיפטי.
חמישים
אלף גברים. דברים ידועים.
זאת אומרת, אתה לא יכול לבוא היום ולהגיד
שזה הרגע זה המרכז של כל המלחמה ולהגיד קודם זה
מלחמה הקהילתית
ואחר כך זה בכינון מדינתית.
זה אבסורד
מבחינה היסטורית, אקדמית, מדעית. זה מה שאני אומר.
לכן אני אומר המלחמה היא אחת מלחמה. אם תקום או לא תקום,
אז היא מתחילה ב כ ט בנובמבר,
והיא נגמרת ב עסקי בשביל את הרשת, כשזה לא שלום.
אבל הייתה הפסקה של העניין הזה, והיו הרבה ההסכמים
שנחתמו
באמצע. אני מסכים. יש שתי תקופות
בתקופה הראשונה
שהמלחמה הייתה בעיקר בין
האוכלוסייה היהודית הישראלית שהיתה בארץ,
גם אם מתנדבים
גם כבר הגיעה גח, אל ומאכל כבר הגיע. אז
אז לא יכולים לתייק
עם הערבים המקומיים, שזה העיקר
עם עזרה של מתנדבים מחוץ לארץ
לבין התקופה השנייה
שבה התחילה
מלחמה בין ישראל ובין מדינות ערב.
אבל מבחינת המהות שלה
היא מלחמה אחת,
ורק כאשר אוטובוס כבשת הנשק,
גם הערבים המקומיים קיבלו את זה באופן מחלימים.
אם הם לא קיבלו את זה,
אז
גם היום הם מקבלים את זה, כי הם מקבלים היום את עסקי בשבילו. את הנשק
של
לעשות אומרת הם מקבלים
את מה שמדינות הרב הם לא חתמו על שום הסכם.
אז מה זה קווי
היום
אומרת לדעתי זה איזו שגיאה
אקדמית היסטורית לנתק את המלחמה בין שניים
אז מתחילה עם הם קראו לזה המלחמה.
כך ההיסטוריונים החדש כמה מהחבר'ה רציני,
אתה יודע את זה החבר'ה הצעירים תמיד הם רוצים להמציא דברים חדשים. הם מגלים את ה
את הגלגל מחדש.
זה לא נכון, אבל זה ויכוח היסטורי.
עכשיו כשאתה חי בדברים וזה דבר אחר, תלוי איפה אתה חי ומה אתה חי.
אז אני הייתי בקרטל בנובמבר שם אז הייתי ולא ידעתי עדיין את המשמעות,
אבל אני חושב ששמעתי את ההצהרה של המדינה.
יש סיסמא. אונו אני זוכר עדיין
נדמה לי את הכל. שהרדיו זה לא ירושלים, אז כנראה היה
באותו בית ש גרתי שם
בזה. ואז יצאנו לבית הכנסת, אני לא זוכר לרחובות ורקדו שם,
ולמחרת הלכנו ללמד כרגיל.
ואז הגישו אותנו.
אז היינו כמה זמן וחזרנו.
אז נעשה רק כל פרק קצר היום על החיים האישיים, החקירה כן, כן, כן, כן,
זו הייתי רק לחזק לך משהו.
הייתי בהרבה מאוד רעיונות בתולדות ישראל. הרבה פעמים מחליקים
ואנשי ההגנה עצם היום
במקום אחר.
כששואלים אותי איפה הייתם, באיזה יראו, מה קרה? מרי
על הכרזות המדינה
אנחנו בעמדה. היינו בקרב בתאריך, הכריזו על המדינה.
אתה יודע, זה כאילו
נכון? נכון, חבל, כבר מזמן הייתה חלק מהיד.
שם. בתל אביב הכריזו על המדינה.
אני אמרתי אני אומר לך, אני שמעתי
בצומת
הכניסה לכביש. שמעתי
שהוא
לועס, אין שום פעולה, ואחר כך
אמרו לי שבאותו זמן
אנחנו שם. כמה ימים היה היה
אלטלנה.
אל תיענינה ירד בכפר ויתקין,
ואני לא יודע. אחרי שאמרו לי אמרתי אולי אני שמעתי להיות שם או משהו. לא, לא שמעתי
על ידי קרוב זה משם על ידי כפר ויתקין. זה
כמה קילומטרים בודדים,
אז אני הייתי שם ואז סיפרו לי ואז אני לא יודע, נראה לי שככה סיפרו לי
אחד עובד, מי אני? אני ידעתי על אלטלנה, לא ידעתי. אמרו לי תיק איתי,
תעצור כל אוטובוס שנכנס פה,
וכל זה אומר שנכנס לכביש הזה הפנימי של גבעת חיים, וכבר
היו שני אנשים או שלושה אנשים. בנינו ובדקנו אותו.
יכול שברו, שברו לו לעצור את כל האוטובוסים שעוברים על הכביש.
היה שם מחסור
ואמרתי קיבוע שעומדים היום שומרים ושמעו במסוף
עולים וכדומה,
ומירי שעשיתי את זה בערב הוא אחרי הצהריים וכדומה.
ולמה אחד הבוקר היו סוגרים לבתי הספר
תלך, תישן שם בגבעת,
בגבעת חיים וישנו שם,
ושמרנו שהוא בכל משמרות כאלה. ואז יום אחד אמרו לנו ש
היחידה של אקסון התקשה את קאקון,
שנלך לשמור בקיקרו לאופן.
לא יצאתי בכפר להסתובב, כי הגזירות לנו מוקשים וכל מיני דברים כאלה,
אבל לא הייתי בקרב ממש, כך שאני לא יכול להגיד שכמו גיסי או כיבו
האבדון שלי, אשתי, שהיו לוחמים גדולים, לא יצא. אני הייתי שם, במקום הזה,
ובספטמבר כבר אמרו לי מספיק, תחזור,
כי המלחמה נגמרה אחרי הפוגה שנייה
אז היה במבצע יואב היה מבצע הנגב, אבל לא היה
תחזור לבית הספר.
ואני חזרתי לבית הספר והייתי שם
או שנה שלמה,
ואפילו יותר מ אפילו שנתיים, ואחר כך רק בשנה, ובתי לאונדס אחר כך.
אז
לגבי בית הספר הזה, שאלה מכיוון אחר
אתה יליד הארץ שהוא לא
תקבע, ואתה פוגש
במושב ולהשיב.
פוגש אוכלוסייה אחרת? כן.
איך היה אבי ורשמה את תמונת חיים או
אני? אמא, היא התימנים היו החברים הכי טובים שלי.
תראה, זה היו תימנים. אני הכרתי הרבה טים, אני מלא
בנשים. ב
איזה תימנים יש האמנים אורגינלים מקוריים כמו
ההתיישבויות התחמניות למונח ביהודה ופתח תקווה,
קימו
ותיקים, ותיקים, ותיקים, לא
אליכין.
זה החדשים.
היש שאלה ועליית כבר רואה אחד אל יחיד
שלא היה קיים בכלל.
יקשיב. זה תימנים. ותיקים,
במשפחות וותיקות ומאוד באמת. זה קיבוץ ימנים בתל אביב.
כמו התימנים בפתח תקוה כמותי נמנעים ברחובות
רק אם אני מאוד נחמדים.
והיו גם בנים גדולים, כבר
העצבים שהיו המייסדים היו לפעמים גם על אנשים שלא ידעו, אולי קרובייך טוב ו חלומה.
אבל הבנים היו באנשים שהיו פעילים
בתנועת העבודה
וגם
את של ולאכיה. ולא כל כך הרבה. רובם היו דווקא
תנועת העבודה, כי הם היו חקלאים,
אז הם היו קשורים ויליאם, משק חלב אליהם, כל בדברים. והם היו אנשים
שרצו שהילדים שלהם יהיו מאוד מזכירים. היה ודאי
זוכר. אנחנו בחור, בשרו יירד. היי,
ילד חמד.
ואני הייתי מאוד קשור. התמסרתי עליהם הרבה מאוד ועבדתי איתם הרבה.
אני זוכר שעזבתי אפילו לתת להם מתנות אישיות. וזה כל מי טבעות כאלה שבצעתי.
ויחד עם שאמרו איתי קשר מכתבים אחר כך,
ואחר כך אבד הקשר.
אבל
שלוש שנים עבדתי שם, אני חושב שלוש שנים. אז השנים האלה שיצא בשבע שמונה
הגעתי ל הגעתי לירושלים ב
חמישים בסוף.
אוקיי,
כן.
ואז עזבתי אותם אחרי שלוש שנים ובאתי ללמוד באוניברסיטה העברית.
אז בסדר. אז אנחנו נעשה פרק ספציפי שהיה לך עם העניין הזה של חקר המלחמה. כן.
וש בדיוק. זה מסתדר בזמן אחרון או לוגיה שאתה
בשביל הכיף
שלו.
אז זהו זה מבחינת המלחמה? עכשיו
רק להתחיל לחייב את ההתחלה. הגעתי לירושלים,
ואז למדתי לתואר ראשון
ובתי ועדיין הייתי דתי.
בעצם, אני כבר בהשקפה לא הייתי דתי,
אבל כל מה שהייתי מורה בבית הספר שם המשכתי ללכת עם הבת שלי.
ואז שאני בא לירושלים עם אניחי ירושלים.
אז הציעו לי משרה באותו בית ספר
באותו שבוע המזרחי
היה בספר לדוגמה,
והייתי שם משרה. אז למה אני הייתי מורה שלוש שנים
בבית הספר, לדוגמה בירושלים?
ויש לי תלמידים וחברי. נו
טוב, ידעתי.
אבל מתי נתחיל המחקר של מלחמת העצמאות?
רק אחרי שאני גומר את הביי
שלוש אני גומר.
מאז שאני גומר את הביי
ניתן לעורך. גם הוא מתחיל את כל הענף. היסטוריה.
אחרי שידידנו אומר,
הרי שידידים גומר את כל הקדנציה שלו כרמטכ ל
יש דורי.
ידין הוא ראש האגף המבצעים שלו.
כשדור היא חולה אחר מלחמה בזמן המלחמה,
דורי לכביכול, לא הרמטכ ל ולהבדיל נוקטים אמצעים
מיידיים. מתחיל להיות רמטכ ל ובאישור המפכ ל שלוש שנים או שנתיים שלוש שנים.
ואז
ובזמן שהוא רמת כאן. נתנאל לורך אני לא יודע כל הזמן הופך להיות ראש הלשכה שלו
כשהיא עדין עוזב את התפקיד שלו ב
של בעלי ארבע. משהו דומה לזה.
אני לא זוכר בדיוק. אפשר למצוא את זה בספרים, אבל זה לא חשוב,
הוא אומר לנתנאל
נותן לו ג'וב
קר ותכתוב את ההיסטוריה של מלחמת העצמאות. תקים את ענף היסטוריה
בשביל זה. דורי
כועס אחר ככה זה. מה פתאום. ידין ממנה את האיש שלו.
אני הייתי הרמטכ ל,
והוא בעצם יוצא נגד לאורך זה לספר לך,
אולי ב כתיבת ההיסטוריה,
שמנת, עצמאות.
ואז
נתנאל
מכיר אותי ויודע שאני
הוא שומע
הולך כנראה ושלמים מהעתודה האקדמית. אנחנו שלוש שנים בעתודה אקדמית
פה בירושלים. היינו בקיץ,
עוברים קורסים
ואחר לא. עברנו גם קורס קצינים
בשני קיצים.
כשאני גומר, אז אני כבר סגל משנה.
ואז אני צריך ללכת לשירות בצה ל, לגמור את אותה שנה
שלא הייתי בא,
כי
הייתי פחות משנה בשני שלב שירות בצה ל.
והוא הלך כנראה וחיפש, והוא יכול לגייס תאמו את שמי. אז הוא בא אליי ואומר
אתה צריך לתת לצה ל. אני לא כן, את הולכת לגמור את הביי בסוף הקיץ?
אני לא רוצה
אומר. אתה מוכן לעבור על אנג'לה והיסטוריה גב?
נראה מי סדור לביבי. אגף הסתובב. זה ג'וב. זה לא,
אבל זה כבר לא היה מלחמה.
ואז
הוא לקח אותי ל סידר את כל הנירות. הייתה לו השפעה, בכל אופן, ראש לשכה.
בסדר, כל ניירות ובתי והתחלתי לעבוד איתו בענף היסטוריה של צה ל,
והוא התחיל לכתוב ואז יצא ספר, הרג את תולדות מלחמת העצמאות.
עבדנו שנתיים שלוש יחד
או שנה שנותן הספר לרצח בשנתיים שלוש מאז שהתחלנו. אז זה הספר הראשון. כן, לו.
איזה סיפור זה יותר מאשר בפעם שעברה.
הוא יום אחד קיבל הודעה מבן גוריון
שהוא רוצה לקראת חמש שנים למדינת ישראל. תעשה את החשבון.
הוא הוציא להוציא ספר המדינה
ובספר. הוא רוצה שיש ספר על מלחמת העצמאות
וניתנה
כן,
ואחר כך דחו את זה כבר. מרי. עשר שנים. אני יודע, בסוף זה לא היה.
בנדל כתב את הספר, והוא כתב את זה על סטן סלים
והחליט להפיץ את זה
בין כל המפקדים של צה ל, שיראו להם הערות, כל האלופים וכל מפקדי חטיבות וכדומה.
יש יד היום בת הסקס הזה. אני יכול להראות לך אותו, אני חושב,
והוא הקפיץ הזה נהיה ב
חמש מאות עותקים. אני לא יודע כמה
ודורי קיבל את העותק הזה,
ואז בדורי ויעשה סקנדל לבן גוריון
מזה לאורך
ממילא אותו
מה פתאום הוא כותב את האשה שאומרת עצמאות.
זה לא נכון. הכל על בסיס מפלגתי. החינוך
בבסיס שלישי
אישי
קיד אורי. בינתיים עברי
וראה שהוא היה מפקדי
צה ל בזמן מלחמת העצמאות ולא
יהיה עדין,
והוא טען שהוא מאדיר את ידין
גורע בחלקו, ובכלל מצא כל בטעויות וכל מיני דברים וכן הלאה.
וישפיע על בן גוריון
ואני זוכר ש
לבגוד, אמר לי
בנטלי לאורך טיסה אל
משהו
אל דורי לדבר איתו. והוא היה הנושא הזה, כמו שהלך לקנוסה
כל יום בו פעם שצריך לנסוע משם,
הוא היה הולך שפוף, היה חוזר לגמרי
בעמותת בינואר, הוא כנראה
עלה עליו לגמרי.
ואז דורי אמר אני
אני לא מסכים שהוא יהיה, והוא אמר
יקימו ועדה
שתבדוק את הספר הזה.
כינסו את ישראל ביר
המפורסם.
זה סיפור שהוא
שהיה אחר כך הורגל. שמעת עליו
תודה,
והוא היה מפתיע שהוא היו הדמות
חזרה
כשהוא היה סגן אלוף בצה ל לא היה הולך בטבעו של שריר.
סגן אלוף.
כשהייתי אומר לו מה זה אומר, זה בזמן שסגן אלוף כשלי הייתה לרעה
וסגן אלוף היה סגן אלוף
תחת לעלות.
כן,
לא היה אלוף. מי שאז עדיין וגם לו הייתה לא יצאת. לא יודעת, אתה לוקח יותר,
בקיצור וקבעו. ודן, ניתן לי להתרגז נורא ואמר
אני מתפטר, קחו ותעשו, אם זה מה שאתם רוצים
והוא עזר, ואנחנו משרד החוץ,
ואז היא כאילו על ישראל בר לכתוב את ההיסטוריה של מלחמת העצמאות.
וגם אתה לא נגישים לכל המסמכים.
בטח. מה זה? הוא היה בן בית אצל החבר של בן גוריון וכדומה.
הוא אגב, כתב מאמר בעוד
הצבאי
היה איש מוכשר
על שלבי מלחמת העצמאות, שזה הפך להיות אחר כך הספר,
המאמר המרכזי של מערכות פרסם וכדומה,
והוא
לא היה צד גדול מאוד.
אני עד היום לא בטוח עם
מה שעשו ממנו אחר כך כדראג '
זה נכון ובצורה כמשפט.
אני חושב שהוא היה שוויצר גדול והוא היה בהופר גדול
והוא הלך, התהדר
בדברים האלה ונכון שהוא נפגש אחר כך
אם הרוסים וכדומה. אבל
אני אני לא היה כבר בעיתונות והנהגה שהוא כאילו שלחו אותו בילד הספרדים והוא
נטו אותו עושים מראש.
אני חושב שזה מוגזם.
ואז הללו לראש
הוא כתב מאמר גדול על הטרון
כשרק הר אניטה שפירא בספר של השתמשה בזה מאוד
והוא טען ש
בשבחך את בן גוריון עד השמיים.
שריון הציל
בית רידג'לי נתן הקרדיט יותר ליד. אין
על כל קרב לטרון.
זה מצא חן בעיני. בן גוריון שירת להגיד שזה כבר קודם. אז אמרנו תכתוב את כל ההיסטוריה
שאני חושבת עצמאות.
אבל הוא לא עשה כלום.
רק
היה מסתובב ב במטכ ל והתחיל להתחבר עם כל מיני אנשים
וכנראה נסע לגרמניה ושם נפגשתם. לרוסים
יש הסיפור של אהרון כהן, אם אתה יודע
זה
נשאר המרכיבים. לא היה
ערבי. סת ידוע
היא שומר הצעיר
שהיה קשור, והוא נפגש איתו בקיבוץ שער העמקים
והביא איתו.
סאנו נפגש עם איזה סוכן רוסי.
ומי זה התחילו כל העיניים, הריגול וכנראה שהוא העביר כבר.
הרוסים ידעו איך לשחוט בבנינו.
אני לא בא להצדיק אותו
וכדומה, אבל אני חושב שזה לא הדבר נטוע מראש
מישהו
מזמן ויאמר
אני חושב שזה התפתח אצלו
ברגע שהראש הללו לזה, ואולי הוא חשב שהוא
בכלל הרוסים היו חברים שלנו, הם שלחו את הרי
את
הנשק, השחי וכדומה,
והוא הסתבך, כמו שבלי שהוא יגיש והסתבר להסתדר.
אבל אז יצא ש
שגם
לא יצא שום דבר. במלחמת העצמאות נשאר הסתר של הזה,
ואז בידי בחור בשם גד מזור. עכשיו קראתי בעיתון לפני חודש שהוא נפטר.
הוא היה שם בתפקיד חשוב בקציר חינוך ראשי.
אצל זאב היה אלוף זאב משורר
זה
ואמר לי תראה, אני רוצה
ש
שביצע לקצינים
ומקיפים,
והם הם ידעו קצת על מלחמת העצמאות. האם אתה יכול
להוציא לי מזה
פרשיות קרב?
ואז אני הוצאתי, עשיתי בזה וזה עשה פרקי ההסברה למלחמת העצמאות
עם פרסם ארבע אני אראה לך. אני חושב שיש לי פה איזה עותק. אם לא התקלקל עדיין
וזה יצא הספר הראשון שעשה ו
זה היה קיצור
של הספר של טיילר. היה
שמי לא מופיע שם בכלל
ואפילו בהקדמה
אני כתבתי ענף היסטוריה של צה ל, כי זה לא היה שלי. אני
הרחתי את זה. אני זוכר עד היום את החדר שישבתי פה, בעלי חדר, עדיין לא הייתי נשוי.
ישבתי וכתבתי את זה
ו
ועשיתי ביפ אותם, הפרוטה משלי. כמעט כולם היו שרטטו אותם.
ואז
אני חזרתי לאוניברסיטה. יום אחד יציעו לי ג'רום
ובאיזה מילה אתה לבודד מי,
אבל
זה, וחזרתי רבות.
ואז בהוצאת מערכות
ואמרה ניקח את זה ונושאים מזה ספר.
ביקשו וביו לשכתוב מבוא גדול
ולקחו את הפרקים האלה כפי שהם,
בלי לשנות שום דבר, אלא אם אבוא
וחיברו אותם יחד
בלי כל ההערות המתודות שלי לירות ביתו דיות
למה אני מביא זר? אז אני הוצאתי
את
פרשת דיר יאסין כי
לא התכוונתי שהם לא הולכים לדון בכל המון פרשיות. לא דיברתי על בבקשה, ג'נין
למשל, שם היה קרב,
לקחתי פרשיות קרב, זה נקרא פרשיות קרב,
והם קראו לזה
תולדות מלחמת הקוממיות. כי זה השם
של
שבע. גירעון יצא.
וזה הספר הראשון שיצא
אז היום הראשון אלה
ג'נין ונגדיר ישים ולג'ני לדיון בדירה. סיבוב להבין
אין את אלנה. אין עלתה לנה. למה? אבל למה?
מה שהשיקול היה פרשיות קרב שקצינים שולחים בשטח.
הם הולכים לאיזה מקום, יוכלו להסביר את המקום,
תראה איך שזה בנוי ויש הערות ביתו דיות. אז הבעיה שנתנו לזה שם
כללי שבטח
הרוויחו מזה הון תועפות
שם שכולו צעד מערכות
ואחרי זה אולי במאה אלף עותקים,
בלי להזכיר ש אז כן, כן,
ו
יש
לך כמו לחמניות.
ואז ניתן לעורך, התרגז על זה
והלך והוציא באופן פרטי
את הדפים האלה שנעשה
כשהוא משפר אותם
ו מתקן אותם להוציא ספר שנקרא תולדות מלחמת העצמאות.
ותראה, זה יצא ב.
אני חושב
מה שיאשש
וזה יצא שם שנתיים אחר כך
והצלת אותו לדין על זה שהוא לקח מסמך
ופרסם את זה באופן פרטי.
ואז הוא הסביר בערך את כל הדברים האלה בסוף
יפילו אותו.
אז יש תולדות, מלחמת הכל במהירות. יש לנו שלפעמים את העצמאות
ולפניכם יש פרקי ההסברה, ולפני כן יש
ספר,
ספר המדינה.
אז אל עכשיו הולך, בין אם מוריס ועוד קבלי אחרים
הולכים לספר לכם את הקבלות, וההיסטוריה רשמית של מלחמת
במדינת ישראל הזה היה להעלים את פרשת אלטלנה
ולהרים את פרשת
ד'יר יסיר לדברים אחרים. אתה רואה איך מתווכחים על הדברים האלה. אז יום אחד עשו כנס.
אני עזבתי את יושב בעצמו.
לא עסקתי בזה אולי עשר שנים.
יום אחד הסוכנים שלי בזה אומר כבר
באוניברסיטה העברית,
האוניברסיטה העברית על מלחמת העצמאות. ויש שם קדישא לא, נו, היום
ראש אגף היסטוריה ובדיקה דר
אפילו לא סיפרו לי. ואז הוא פתאום חלב
היה לא יזכיר את הביטוח. הוא לא יכול לבוא את שאריות.
אז ביילי קידר ידעת שלנו ויהושע, תעשה לי טובה.
תבוא, תציל, תספר קצת.
אז באתי ומספרת להם את כל הסיפור הזה בשעתיים. הרצאה
איך נכתבה בכלל?
איך נכתבה בכלל ההיסטוריה שהם קוראים לזה היסטוריה עצמית.
זה לא היסטוריה רשמית וזו היסטוריה אישית
שנתנדנד. עורך כתב
ויעשו מזה מה שעשו.
ואז הוא המונית לפרסם ופרסמתי על זה במאמר גדול,
מעטים מול רבים,
בתוך חוברת של מציאות
והיות וניתן לילה עזב
ואחד היה בחור בשם דוג שבכנסייה הוא
שהוא
היה קשור קצת והוא גם כן עזב. היה עוד
בחור שעזב. אני נשארתי היחיד שהייתי קשור לזה,
אז המשכתי לארצות, לארצות. ובכן, את העצמאות,
עד שמורה לברונטית יודע מזה ברור לברור.
הוא בא אליי יום אחד ואומר לי הוא שאמרתי לדבר. אני לא זוכר שאמרתי לך.
הוא היה הוא היה אחרי שתענה לאורך
אז היה גבי כהן, ראש ענף אשתו, איזה זמן שאחר כך פרופסור בתל אביב,
ובזמנו אני
קדאפי. לאחר, כאמור הלה בארון
ולספר לך זה גם בימים. בהזדמנות נוספת.
ואז הוא אמור לי יום אחד תפס אותי ברחוב ואומר
חנה רובינא ממשיכה לשחק הדיבוק ואתה ממשיך להרצות על מחבת עצמו.
אז זה גם מה אותי
אמרתי שאני מזוהה, ומאז ידעתי שאני מפסיק להרצות על מכללת עצמאות.
טלפונים בלי סוף יום.
עצמאות, יורשים, אמרת לי יוק.
אני לא מרצה
על מלחמת העצמאות ועברתי לגמרי לתחומים אחרים
של ביוגרפיה הסטורית.
אבל את זקנה.
החזירו אותי
מאוד
במלחמת העצמאות וכתבתי להם את זה.
אבל אני יכול לספר לך עוד על מלחמת העצמאות של הדברים האלה.
אני זוכר את זה ועוד
היה יום אחד שיצאנו לסיום. אתה לאורך, לקח כל מיני סוגי הרופאים, עושים כוס
ללמוד. מלחמת העצמאות הביא סגני אלופים,
אלופי משנה,
אנשים יוצאים מן הכלל יסמנו לישון בדרך בובה
ועוד לא לפינוי דרך דרומה ועלינו על מוקשים
בשני סגני אלופים הרגו במוקשים
על חוקה,
שני בחורים
אלופים, מה שהם לא עברו בקרבות,
מי יודע על זה היום? אף אחד לא יודע.
אני חושב שזו הייתה שגיאה שלו. על הייתה ההשקעה של מי שלחו לד ר בובה
נסענו בשרת ג'אפר. פתאום ג'יפ אחד עלה על מוקש, ישבנך אדום אש, ואז קרו כל מיני הסודות
על משהו. זה כבר היה ב.
הוא היה בן שנים אחר כך.
בקיצור, היו שם כל מיני סיפורים. גם ישראל באר זה סיפור אחד.
ניתנת לך רק להריח
מהסיפורים האלה, ואני מציע שהסתפק היום.
תודה רבה,
אני
זה לא דבר קבוע. סיפורים
של הגיוס שלי
והבן דוד של
שזו דרישה שלי. אבל
לא מלחמות. לא
לא קבורה. אבל אני אחר
עולם אחר. בניתוח היסטורי של המלחמה אני יכול
לתת לך ושיתחילו אפילו בתקופת המנדט זה יכול להיות דווקא מעניין.
אז אני רוצה להגיד את זה פשוט אני רוצה להבין תגבורת איתי לפגישה
בבקשה.
אתמול. דיסני
הוא מומחה לידיעת הארץ ומדריך
כמעט שנה, והוא יראה
ידבר איתך
על חקר המלחמה
ברצון רב
ולא פרטי של דבר
בסדר שלו,
כי
כי אני עכשיו כאשר הרבה בתקופת המנדט
ואני קושרת את הדברים האלה. היה לי ויכוח על האטימות, לגולני את הבית, הרבה קריאה.
אני
הצעה לוויכוח יותר עכשיו הייתי גם בזה. פורמן דת בחיפה ויוצאת עליי
בבקשה.
אז נעשה פעם אחרת.
ניתן קצת לנוח.
כן,
ואשר השאלה הגדולה הוא היה מוטי גולני.
מאלה שטוענים שהבריטים היו עוזבים בכל מקרה, בלי שום
קשר, הוא לא תואם לזה. זה טוב. שגב כתב פעם בספר שלו ימי הכלליות.
לדעתי זה גם כן הבשורות.
איפה הם רצו לעזוב? זה שטויות לבצע זאת.
אפילו במכתב. את החלוקה אם עדיין לא רצו לעשות
האמת, תמיד החלוקה. אם
הם
דיברו על בסיסיים. ועידת פעילות. דיברו על ירושלים
למנדט בינלאומי. ירושלים זה מדינת ירושלים.
ומה ב
במבצע קדש
הם תוקפים את תאלצו. עץ יחד איתנו
בקנוניה הזו
אידל,
שזה דבר האבסורדי היום לעשות.
אז הם עושים את זה ב
הבעלים של בתי הזיקוק.
כן, ועדיין תלעסו. את
חשובה להם.
נכון שאת וג'ון עוזבים, אבל
הם גם פה. הם רצו להישאר בחיפה, בבסיסים בחיפה
ורצו להקים בסיסים גדולים ברפיח
ולי להקים
בסיני בסיס גדול.
נכון שהם היו מוכנים
בוועדת פיל
שתקום מדינה יהודית, מדינה ערבית,
אבל הם רצו לשלוט בחלק גדול
במדינת ירושלים,
שזה כולל יפו, שזה כולל לוד ורמלה. מזה תופעה
זה כואב. נמל חיפה,
זאת אומרת, הם שילוב קצת המדיניות, אבל מכאן ועד לעזוב.
אז מה? אם הם רצו לעזוב, הם היו
תולים את
את
העולה הגדול ו הסרג'נטים, וכל המאבק שלהם נגד כאן
ובבין והמפעילים.
אם הם רוצים לעזור,
אה, לבוא, להגיד
היה ממש
מה אתם עושים פה?
לא, הוא טוען טענה אחרת שבו ט גולני
שכאילו
היה פה עשיתי זה כנס. פעם הוא אמר שאהוד ברק עשה בקמפ דייוויד.
מה שבן גוריון היה מוכן לעשות ב
ב
ועדת פיל
כי
הגיוני מוכן לחלוקתה של ירושלים,
ושבה רק לקחת רעיון. מה שאמרתי לו את זה
זה לא נכון, מפני שאם הוא היה בן גוריון רצה. ועוד אמר
החלק המערבי היהודי שסופח למדינת ישראל,
מהמנדט הבריטי,
יישאר על העיר העתיקה
ולהיפך, תיקח אותו מזרחה
תכניס את
השומרוני הטוב
ותגיע די יוחנן המטביל,
ושם יהיה פס
שיהיה קדוש, לא נוצרים.
זאת אומרת, זה יש קפא לגמרי אחרת.
ירושלים היהודית. אתה מצרף שזיהם אלף יהודים. אתה לא יכול בלי זה
מה שברק. ההצעה של בגין בוויזה לחלק את ירושלים, כולל את העיר עתיקה
שהרוב המוסלמי
מוסלמי הגבוה הוא יבוא בכל כבית משוגעים. מישהו כאן משוגעים באישום קל
ואחד ירה
טילים על השינים בתוך העיר עתיקה.
זה דבר נורא,
הוא אם נגיד,
חשב,
אני לא יודע אם הוא חשב בכלל הזה,
הוא בכלל היה פרגמטיסט. הוא אמר
ל הועלם. תקח מה שאתה יכול, נותנים לי את החלק המערבי, אני כך
שיהיה. בינתיים מנדט, מי יודע מה יהיה אחר כך. אחר כך הלאה.
או שיהיה. אולי חשב, משליכה על האגן הקדוש
מן הוותיקן,
זה אני יכול לחשוב,
אבל יש תעודות מפורשות. שבועי, בתנאי,
בתנאי מפורש,
שהחלק השני
יישאר
מנדט בריטי.
לא שהחלק השני
היא ערבי,
וזה הבדל עצום בתפיסה.
לכן אי אפשר לומר
שזה אותה תפיסה.
מי שרוצה היום לקבל חיזוק שהפיתרון בעתיד אולי
זה שהעיר העתיקה יהיה בין הוותיקן
יכול להסתמך על בן גוריון.
וגם הלוואי ספן שאמרו
אנחנו לא רוצים את הקבר הקדוש והמקומות הקדושים לא רוצה להסתבך,
אבל הם לא היו מוכנים שזה יהיה ערבי
הם היו מוכנים שזה יהיה בין סטטוס בינלאומי. אפילו
אולמרט החכם שאני לא מסכים,
אמר בואו ניצור איזה מין סטטוס
זהו, אפשר לעשות הקבלה.
אבל בואו נגיד שזה. ואז אני
הייתי יושב ראש, איזה כנס, ויצאתי נגדו ונגד החבר השני,
יוסי כץ. פרופסור תלמיד שלי.
הוא ימני. הוא גר פעם לגבי
בגוש עציון והוא,
אבל הם יצאו פתאום.
אז זה מסוכן מאוד מבחינה אקדמית לעשות הגבלות
היסטוריות.
כל זמן זו התקופה שלו.
מה שהיה ב
זה סיפור אחד.
מה שיהיה ב
זה סיפור אחד,
מה שהיום זה סיפור אחד
אתה יכול לעשות הגבלות, אבל
כי זה היה מאוד בלי להגיד
מי לחכות. להגיד מה שהיה זה מה שהיה היום
זה לא
אותו דבר,
אז היו תאים אחרים. אז אם השירות, כמו ששאלת אותי,
מה חשבו אז?
איך קיבלו אז את הדברים?
ככה צריך להיות. עצר לראות
את הדברים ברוח. התקופה
אכן קרה
בשרירי ההיסטורית, ואני אכין. קראת לסבוא שלי עיר ברי תקופה.
אם אתה לא רואה את התקופה,
זה לא נכון. הבינו בתקופת המנדט
אתה לא יכול לראות את תקופת המנדט כי בקשה אחת
ראשית, המנדט זה סיפור אחר.
סוף המנדט זה סיפור אחר. באמצע מדד
אין גבולות ברורים, אבל הדברים משתנים.
טרייסי משתנה.
כן, ובבין זה לא ברפורד
בספר שכתב
ספר סקס. הבן של מקס פיין,
מ
מ. באלפור ועד בויד.
זה שינוי דרסטי בכל מידע. בדיוק. אתה לא יכול לדבר
על הבריטי במדד. צריך שעלול באיזה עניין? באיזה נושא?
טוב, נתתי גם קצת על
ציונות.
כן,
טוב,
מצוין.
כן.
הכרתם? סבבה. קורס מורי. דרך יום
אחר כך. אני
באמת יפה. יש לנו יצאנו.
כן?
כן. ומה אתה עייף? אתה גר היום?
אני גם בית הלוי,
לא?